GOOD AFTERNOON I WANT TO WELCOME
EVERYONE TO TODAY'S JOINT
INFORMATIONAL HEARING BETWEEN
THE ASSEMBLY HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY. DEVELOPMENT COMMITTEE
AND THE ASSEMBLY LOCAL
GOVERNMENT COMMITTEE.
MY NAME IS DAVID CHIU I CHAIR
THE ASSEMBLY HOUSING COMMITTEE
AND IN A MOMENT I WILL TURN IT
OVER TO THE CHAIR OF THE
ASSEMBLY LOCAL GOVERNMENT
COMMITTEE.
BUT TODAY'S HEARING IS TO DO A
REVIEW AND ANALYSIS OF CURRENT
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT TOOLS.
I THINK EVERYONE KNOWS THAT
REDEVELOPMENT WAS ONE OF THE
MAIN TOOLS USED BY LOCALS TO
FUND AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND MANY
OTHER THINGS. AND IT'S A LOSS
FROM MY PERSPECTIVE IS THE CHAIR
OF THE HOUSING COMMITTEE HAS
HELPED TO CONTRIBUTE TO OUR
CURRENT HOUSING CRISIS.
AT THE TIME OF DISSOLUTION
REDEVELOPMENT AGENCIES WERE
OBLIGATED TO SPEND OVER A
BILLION DOLLARS A YEAR ON
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. AND.
IT HAS BEEN DOCUMENTED THAT THE
LOSS OF THESE FUNDS HAS
ACCOMPANIED A RISE IN
HOMELESSNESS AND THE CRISIS THAT
WE'RE IN RIGHT NOW. WITH REGARDS
TO AFFORDABILITY.
NOW IN THE WAKE OF REDEVELOPMENT
THE LEGISLATURE CREATED VARIOUS
TOOLS TO FUND INFRASTRUCTURE AND
AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
A SMORGASBORD OF ACRONYMS
CREUS YEAH OF DIS HA IS NIFTY
SITS.
ALL OF THESE TOOLS ARE VOLUNTARY
FOR CITIES AND COUNTIES THAT
WANT TO USE A PORTION OF
PROPERTY TAX INCREMENT.
BUT WHAT WE HAVE DISCOVERED IS
THAT THESE TOOLS HAVE NOT.
BOEING LARGE OF BEEN AS ROBUST
AS REDEVELOPMENT.
AND WE WILL CERTAINLY HEAR A
LITTLE BIT MORE THIS AFTERNOON
ABOUT WHY THAT IS THE CASE.
OF THE GOAL OF TODAY'S HEARING
IS TO EXPLORE THE LANDSCAPE OF
THE POST REDEVELOPMENT WORLD.
LOOK AT VARIOUS TOOLS EXAMINE
HOW THEY'RE WORKING.
GIVEN OUR STATE STABLE FISCAL
HEALTH AT THIS POINT.
THERE IS A LOT OF INTEREST AND
THINKING ABOUT HOW WE CAN
FURTHER INVEST IN HOUSING AND
INFRASTRUCTURE. I WILL MENTION.
THAT I AM I HAVE BEEN CONVENING.
LITTLE BIT OF A WORKING GROUP
WITH A. A VARIETY OF OF MEMBERS
OF THE LEGISLATURE THAT RESPECT
REFLECT I THINK THAT THE
DIVERSITY OF OUR LEGISLATURE.
THERE IS DEFINITELY INTEREST
AND THINKING ABOUT HOW WE MOVE
LEGISLATION FOR IN THIS AREA AND
PART OF THIS HEARING. IS TO.
INFORM THAT PROCESS SO WITH
THAT. I'M GONNA TURN IT OVER TO
MY CULTURE.
GOOD AFTERNOON AND THANK YOU FOR
ALL KINDS.
I AM ALSO ONE I THINK THE
COMMITTEE STAFF AND OTHER
COMMITTEE MEMBERS WHO WILL BE
PRODUCED IN SUPPORT DISCUSSION
TODAY. I JUST SEE WILL BE HAVING
PEOPLE COMING AND GOING BECAUSE
OF NUMEROUS WHO COMMITTEE
MEETINGS. MY GOAL TODAY IS TO
WALK AWAY WITH AN UNDERSTANDING
OF THE PAST THE PRESENT AND SOME
TAKEAWAYS FOR THE FUTURE.
WILD REDEVELOPMENT AGENCIES ARE
NOT THE TOPIC OF TODAY'S HEARING
WE CAN'T HAVE THE CONVERSATION
ABOUT CURRENT TAX INCREMENT
TOOLS WITHOUT ACKNOWLEDGING HOW
WE GOT HERE.
I LOOK FORWARD TO HEARING ABOUT
THE CURRENT TOOLS WHETHER
THEY'RE WORKING HEARING REASONS
WHY THEY MAY NOT BE. AND A
LISTEN TO OUR SPEAKERS PROVIDE
OVERALL ANALYSIS ABOUT THE STATE
OF COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT IN OUR
LOCAL COMMUNITIES.
I'M ALSO VERY INTERESTED IT TO
HEAR THE FINAL PANEL ON OTHER
PERSPECTIVES
AND WHAT THEY HAVE TO SAY
ESPECIALLY WHEN IT COMES TO
UNDERSTAND THE NEEDS OF OUR
RURAL COMMUNITIES. LIKE MY
DISTRICT.
WE CANNOT LEAVE OUR RURAL
COMMUNITIES OUT OF THIS
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT
DISCUSSION.
WITH THAT I LIKE TO BRING UP
BRIAN MUELLER OR FROM THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE TO
HELP US SET THE TABLE ON TAX
INCREMENT AS A COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT TOOL WELCOME.
RIGHT THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME
OWE YES I'VE BEEN ASKED TO
PROVIDE US SOME BACKGROUND ON
TAXING GROUP FINANCING IN
CALIFORNIA.
IN GENERAL A TAX INCREMENT
FINANCING IS A TOOL THAT LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS IN CALIFORNIA AND
THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY HAVE USED
FOR MANY YEARS.
TO FINANCE A VARIETY OF
PROJECTS TO BE THAT VERY SUBS OF
INFRASTRUCTURE OR PUBLIC
REVITALIZATION AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT PROJECTS OR.
AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
IN GENERAL TAX INCREMENT
FINANCING A WORKS BY HAVING A
LOCAL GOVERNMENT IDENTIFY A
PORTION OF THEIR JURISDICTION.
THAT THEY FEEL NEEDS SOME SOME
ADDITIONAL PUBLIC INVESTMENT.
IN.
MAKING THE DECISION TO ALLOCATE
FUTURE GROWTH AND PROPERTY TAX
REVENUES FROM PROPERTIES WITHIN
THAT AREA.
TO HELP FUND OF THE DESIRED
PROJECTS
AND USUALLY OF THIS WORKS BY A
DEDICATING THE STREAM OF FUTURE
GROWTH IN PROPERTY TAX REVENUES
TO REPAYMENT OF OF A BOND.
IN USING THE BOND PROCEEDS.
TO FUND. THE DESIRED PROJECTS.
FOR MANY YEARS UP UNTIL TWO
THOUSAND TWELVE WHEN IT WAS A
ELIMINATED REDEVELOPMENT
AGENCIES WERE THE.
PRIMARY TOOL USED BY WILL
GOVERNMENT THE PRIMARY TAX
INCREMENT FINANCING TOOL USED BY
A LOCAL GOVERNMENTS.
AND UNDER REDEVELOPMENT A CITY
OR COUNTY A COULD CREATE A
REDEVELOPMENT AGENCY THAT.
THAT IDENTIFIED BROUGHT
REDEVELOPMENT PROJECT AREAS
WITHIN THE JURISDICTION.
.
WITHIN WHICH TAX INCREMENT
FINANCING WOULD BE USED TO FUND
A PLAN OF PUBLIC IMPROVEMENTS
WHICH COULD INCLUDE A VARIETY OF
ACTIVITIES. FROM DIFFERENT TYPES
OF INFRASTRUCTURE TO ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT AND STATE LAW
REQUIRED THAT TWENTY PERCENT OF
THE FUNDING I HAD TO GO.
TOWARDS FURTHERING THE
CONSTRUCTION OF HOUSING THAT WAS
AFFORDABLE A FOR HOUSEHOLDS WITH
LOW AND MODERATE INCOME.
NO REDEVELOPMENT.
BEFORE TERMINATION WAS A VERY
POPULAR AMONG WILL GOVERNMENTS.
THERE WERE FOUR HUNDRED AND
TWENTY SEVEN AGENCIES A
STATEWIDE THAT OVERSAW SEVEN
HUNDRED AND FORTY THREE A
PROJECT AREAS AND RECEIVED ABOUT
FIVE BILLION DOLLARS STATEWIDE.
IMPROPER TAX REVENUE WHICH AT
THE TIME.
WAS ABOUT TWELVE PERCENT A OF
STATEWIDE PROPERTY TAX REVENUE.
AND NOT MANY FACTORS CONTRIBUTED
TO A MAKING RTA AN ATTRACTIVE A
TAX INCREMENT FINANCING TOOL OF
IT I WANT TO HIGHLIGHT A TWO.
ELEMENTS OF FREE DISCUSSION
TODAY THE FIRST IS.
IN GENERAL WHEN.
CITY OR COUNTY WANTS TO PUT
FORWARD A BOND THAT IS BACKED BY
PROPERTY TAXES TO FUND
INFRASTRUCTURE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING. IN GENERAL THAT
REQUIRES THEM TO RECEIVE A TWO
THIRDS VOTE OF THEIR A LOCAL
ELECTORATE TO MOVE THAT BOND
FORWARD.
UNDER REDEVELOPMENT A CITY OR
COUNTY COULD THROUGH THE
REDEVELOPMENT AGENCY ISSUE A
BOND THAT WAS BACKED BY THE
GROWTH IN PROPERTY TAXES.
AND AND THE ISSUANCE OF THAT
BOND I DIDN'T REQUIRE A FURTHER
APPROVAL FROM.
VOTERS.
A SECOND ELEMENT IS THAT
REDEVELOPMENT GAVE A.
CITIES AND COUNTIES ACCESS TO
REVENUES THAT THEY OTHERWISE
WOULD NOT HAVE HAD ACCESS TO. ON
THIS IS BECAUSE OF THE WAY THAT
PROPERTY TAX ALLOCATION A WORKS
IN CALIFORNIA.
A LOCAL GOVERNMENTS DO NOT HAVE
THE AUTHORITY TO INDEPENDENTLY
LEVY A TAX READING COLLECT.
PROPERTY TAX REVENUES FROM THE
PROPERTIES THEY SERVE INSTEAD.
EACH PROPERTY PAYS A SET ONE
PERCENT RATE.
AND THE REVENUES DERIVED FROM
THAT ONE PERCENT RATE ARE
DIVVIED ACROSS ALL THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS THAT SERVE THAT
PROPERTY SO USUALLY A CITY.
A COUNTY A SCHOOL DISTRICT AND
VERY SUCH A SPECIAL DISTRICT ME
LIKE A FIRE DISTRICT OUR LIBRARY
DISTRICT.
AND THE DIVVYING UP OF THOSE
REVENUES ACROSS LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS IS DETERMINED BY
FORMULA SUDDEN STAY LOST OF
THESE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS DON'T
HAVE.
TROLL OVER THE ALLOCATION OF
THESE PROPERTY TAX REVENUES.
UNDER REDEVELOPMENT A A CITY OR
COUNTY COULD AGAIN CONTROL OVER.
NOT JUST THEIR SHARE OF THE
GROWTH IN PROPERTY TAX REVENUES
FROM A SET OF PROPERTIES. ABOUT
THE REVENUE.
THIS YEAR'S REVENUES THAT WOULD
HAVE GONE A TO OTHER LOCAL
ENTITIES.
AS WELL.
AND.
THIS DID HAVE FISCAL
IMPLICATIONS FOR THE OTHER A
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS A. AND IT HAS
FISCAL IMPLICATIONS FOR THE
STATE AS WELL.
ALTHOUGH THE STATE DOESN'T
RECEIVE PROPERTY TAX REVENUE.
STATE FINANCING SCHOOL FINANCING
LAWS REQUIRE THAT SCHOOL
DISTRICTS RECEIVE A MINIMUM
LEVEL OF FUNDING THROUGH A
COMBINATION OF LOCAL PROPERTY
TAX REVENUE. AND ST JOURNAL FUND
DOLLARS.
AND SO WHEN A LOCAL PROPERTY TAX
REVENUES ALLOCATED TO SCHOOLS.
ARE REALLOCATED TO OTHER
PURPOSES.
LIKE.
REDEVELOPMENT A COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT.
THEN STATE GENERAL FUND DOLLARS
ESSENTIALLY HAVE TO THE BACK
FILL THOSE THOSE PROPERTY TAX
REVENUES.
IN THE IN THE LAST YEAR BEFORE
IN THE LAST YEAR OF
REDEVELOPMENT ACTIVITY.
THIS AMOUNT OF PROPERTY TAX
REVENUE REALLOCATED FROM SCHOOLS
WAS ABOUT TWO BILLION DOLLARS
STATEWIDE WHICH NECESSITATED. A
TWO BILLION DOLLAR GENERAL FUND.
BACKFILL TO SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
AND SO WHILE THIS รณ THIS WAS
AN ATTRACTIVE FEATURE OF
REDEVELOPMENT AGENCIES FOR MANY
CITIES AND COUNTIES. IT ALSO A
CREATED SOME TENSIONS BECAUSE
YOU HAD IN MANY CASES ONE ACTOR
THAT WAS MAKING A DECISION THAT
HAD FISCAL IMPLICATIONS FOR MANY
INTERESTED PARTIES.
A AND THIS IS.
ATTENTION THAT CREATED OTHER
DROVER FORMS OR REDEVELOPMENT
WAS IN PLACE AND ULTIMATELY.
LEAD TO CONTRIBUTED TO ITS
ELIMINATION.
.
AND A.
DEALING WITH THIS TENSION IS ONE
OF THE THE KEY DIFFERENCES THAT
SEPARATES OF REDEVELOPMENT
AGENCIES FROM THE CURRENT TAX
INCREMENT FINANCING. TOOLS THAT
ARE IN PLACE TODAY.
WHERE IS REDEVELOPMENT ALLOWED
A LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO A GAIN?
ACCESS TO ALL OF THE PROPERTY
TAXES OF THE PROPER TEXTURES OF
ALL OF THE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS.
THE NEW TOOLS WHAT YOU'LL HEAR
MORE ABOUT FROM THE LATER PANEL
SUCH AS THAT IT ENHANCE
INFRASTRUCTURE FINANCING
DISTRICTS IN THE QUEUE COMMUNITY
REVITALIZATION INVESTMENT AREAS.
THEY ARE MORE LIMITED IN SCOPE.
ALLOWING ESSENTIALLY A CITY OR
COUNTY TO GAIN ACCESS TO THEIR
SHARE OF GROWTH IN PROPERTY TAX
REVENUES.
AS WELL AS THE SHARES OF ANY
NON EDUCATIONAL LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS THAT WOULD WANT TO
PARTICIPATE.
IN THE PUBLIC IMPROVEMENTS OF
IT WOULD NOT ALLOW.
THE CITIES AND COUNTIES TO GAIN
ACCESS TO THIS THE SCHOOL SHARE
OF THE PROPERTY TAX REVENUE
GROWTH.
AND SO WITH THAT I'M HAPPY TO
TAKE ANY QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
THE BILL EVERY QUESTIONS.
NO ONE FROM THE COMMITTEE FLORA
GENSCHER OFTEN I GUESS BECAUSE I
WAS A GOOD SUMMER. AS A REALLY
GOOD SUMMARY WE'VE ALL BEEN
LOCAL GOVERNMENT SO WE CAN GET
BACK. AT THE HISTORY OF IT WAS
VERY IMPORTANT SO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND APPRECIATE. YOUR TIME
ON THIS SO WHY WE MOVE ON TO OUR
PANEL ON THE ANALYSIS OF POST
REDEVELOPMENT TAX INCREMENT
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT TOOLS. AND
THEM RODIN CARING FOR YOU COULD
JOIN US AIR CALDWELL AND MICHAEL
LANE.
AND DAMN IT WILL START WITH YOU.
.
DAN IS WITH THE CALIFORNIA
LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA CITIES.
AND WE'VE SEEN HIM MANY TIMES
BEFORE BUT WELCOME BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE A GOOD AFTERNOON OUR
CHAIRS AND.
MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME
HERE TODAY.
I DO HAVE A A POWER POINT TO
MAKE SURE WITH COMMITTEE I
BELIEVE YOU HAVE A HANDOUT BUT
USE THAT IS CUT THE BASIS FOR MY
REMARKS.
HE HAD SORT OF.
BUILDING OFF OF.
THAT THE LEGISLATURE WHICH
ANALYSTS ON COMMENTS UP ONE OF
THE THINGS TO UNDERSTAND ABOUT
REDEVELOPMENT ARM WAS. BEFORE
YOU CAN EVEN SET UP A
REDEVELOPMENT AGENCY THERE HAD
TO BE THIS ANALYSIS IN THESE
FINDINGS THAT WHAT FOR
REDEVELOPMENT THE AREA WASN'T
GONNA GET FIXED WASN'T GONNA GET
FIXED BY THE PRIVATE SECTOR
BOND.
IF THERE WERE BROWNFIELDS RATHER
SORT OF PROBLEMS.
IT END IN MAYBE THE GOVERNMENT
ACTED ALONE SO THAT WAS KIND OF
THIS THING THAT WE WE REALLY
NEED TO A POWERFUL TOOL.
IN THIS AREA OF A IN SO ANYWHERE
THERE'S THIS IDEA BUT FOR AND
SO.
INTO IN THE IN THE PIE CHART
I'VE GOT FROM THE PRIOR ALREADY
A FUNDING HOME THE ELLIS IS
CORRECT WHEN YOU SET UP ONE OF
THESE ON ONE OF THESE AREAS YOU
COULD TARGET A SIGNIFICANT
FINANCIAL LIFT INTO INTO FIXING
WHATEVER THE PROBLEM WAS.
NO THERE WAS A PROVISION IN THE
REAR REDEVELOPMENT LAW FOR PASS
THROUGHS TO BE NEGOTIATED AT IN
SOME COUNTIES SO THEY THEY WERE
ABLE TO GET MONEY.
AS AS THE PROJECT GREW
SOMETIMES WAS WERE NEGOTIATED
SOMETIMES THEIR WORK OR NOT BUT
CERTAINLY THE SCHOOL SHARE AND
THE IMPLICATIONS ON ON PROP
NINETY EIGHT WERE WERE WERE PART
OF THE ISSUE. NOW.
WE'VE ENTERED INTO.
THAT HE A SORT OF THE POST
REDEVELOPMENT WORLD AND WE HAVE
A NUMBER OF OF NEW ATTACKS AND
COMMIT TOOLS IN YOUR ANALYSIS
KINDA WALKS THROUGH THEM.
AND.
A COUPLE OF THINGS I WANNA I
WANNA POINT OUT WITH YOU COULD
HAVE SOME DIFFERENCES ESPECIALLY
WITH ENHANCE INFRASTRUCTURE
FINANCE DISTRICTS WILL GET INTO
THAT IN IT A BIT MORE. BOOK BUT
WITH REDEVELOPMENT IT WAS ABOUT
THE WHERE YOU KNOW WAS THE AREA
BLIGHTED DID IT MEET CERTAIN
CONDITIONS THAT WORK THAT ALLOW
THIS TOOL TO BE USED SO SO THE
WHERE MATTERED A LOT.
WITH E. IFD ARM YOU YOU REALLY
THE ONLY BOUNDARIES OF ANY IFD
OR POLITICAL AGREEMENT.
AND FOR FOR THE.
MISS SUPPORTER CURRIES A ISSUES
WITH THE RURAL AREAS IT THIS IS
DIFFERENT AND ACTUALLY I THINK
HELP FOR IT WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT
IN RURAL AREAS IT AND HENCE
SOLVING MAY SURGICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE ISSUES. BECAUSE
IT WAS AT THIS
YOU KNOW YOU MAY NOT BE TRYING
TO CREATE A REVITALIZED DOWNTOWN
OR SOMETHING IN IN A RULER YOU
MAY BE JUST TRYING TO FIX A LEVY
OR DO SOMETHING ELSE SO. YEAH I
IF DIS OR FLEXIBLE ON THE WHERE.
MUCH MORE SO THAN THAN THE
FORMER TOOL AND AND THE CREEL
LAW IS IS BACK TO THE OLD A
REDEVELOPMENT IDEA OF IF WE'RE
GONNA HAVE THESE MORE POWERFUL
TOOLS. THEN YOU KNOW THERE HAS
TO BE SOME FOCUS ON ON WHERE
THOSE TOOLS ARE APPLIED.
.
ONE OF THE THINGS ARE OR THE
THING ALL THESE TOOLS HAVING
CARMEN IS.
THAT YOU CAN TALK TO THE OTHER
TAXING ENTITIES AS A CITY I CAN
TALK TO THE COUNTY I CAN TALK TO
THE SPECIAL DISTRICT TO SEE
WHETHER OR NOT. THEY BE WILLING
TO PARTICIPATE IN AND WHATEVER
OF WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO PUT
TOGETHER A WITH ANY OF THESE
TOOLS. BUT THERE'S NO WAY I CAN
TALK TO THE SCHOOL DISTRICT AND
REALLY IT'S REALLY A STATE ISSUE
WITH WITH PROP NINETY EIGHT SO
YOU REALLY SO FIFTY PERCENT OF
THE REVENUE IF YOU WILL IS SORE
OFF THE TABLE EVEN FOR. A FROM
OUR PERSPECTIVE FROM FROM JUST
EVEN THE DISCUSSION.
IN ADDITION TO TAX INCREMENT
AREN'T JUST COMING FROM THE
GROWTH IN PROPERTY TAX THERE'S A
COUPLE WRINKLES THAT DID BUT
THAT PROVIDE A LITTLE MORE
FLEXIBILITY.
AT IT INTO IN TERMS OF REVENUE
OPTIONS THAT THAT HE AYE OF G.
KOREA AND THIS A AFFORDABLE
HOUSING AUTHORITY TOOL HAVE. IN
IN SO IN ADDITION JUST TO THE
GROWTH THE PROPERTY TAX THERE
SOME OTHER REVENUES THAT THAT
CAN BE USED IN THOSE TOOLS.
THERE'S THE PROPERTY TAX THAT
CITIES AND COUNTIES GET. UP IN
LIEU OF THE VLF THAT THE USED TO
GET SO SO THAT'S PROTECTED UNDER
PROPOSITION ONE EIGHT SO THEY
GET AN ADDITIONAL AMOUNT OF
PROPERTY TAX IN LIEU OF THIS VLF
THAT. THAT WE USE TO GET ALL
ALSO AS REDEVELOPMENT DEBTS WERE
PAID OFF THESE RIDGES RESIDUALS
IT'LL COME BACK TO A CITY COUNTY
OR SPECIAL DISTRICT THESE TOOLS
ALTHOUGH ALSO AUTHORIZE. A THOSE
ENTITIES TO DIRECT SOME OF THOSE
SUMMER ALL THOSE PORTIONS INTO.
THESE DIFFER OUT. AND ARM.
AND THEN THERE ARE A VARIETY OF
ASSESSMENT DISTRICTS AND OTHER
THINGS THAT ARE AUTHORIZED UNDER
OTHER LAWS IT AND ALL THREE OF
THESE LAWS E. AYE IF DE KOREA
AND AFFORDABLE HOUSING
AUTHORITIES. ALLOW YOU TO CUT A
COORDINATE WITH WITH SOME OF
THOSE OTHER.
TOOLS NOW OF COURSE WHATEVER
YOU'RE DOING HAS TO BE
CONSISTENT WITH THOSE LAWS BUT
THAT ALLOW SOME COORDINATION SO
THAT'S DIFFERENT IN A LITTLE
MORE THAN THE OLD. ARE ALREADY A
TOOL HAD HAD BY ITSELF.
YOU KNOW A LOT OF PEOPLE THINK
OF  I A FIFTIES
INFRASTRUCTURE BUT THEY ALSO CAN
FINANCE PRIVATE DEVELOPMENT IF
YOU LOOK AT MY LIST.
UNDER THE UNDER THAT YOU CAN.
FINANCE INDUSTRIAL STRUCTURES.
TRANSIT PRIORITY PROJECTS.
WHATEVER INTEREST ENTRANCE OR
IN DEVELOPMENT HERE PROJECTS
IMPLEMENTING SUSTAINABLE
COMMUNITY STRATEGY YOU COULD
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. AND ARE ALSO
IT SAYS FACILITIES CONSTRUCTED A
HOUSE PROVIDERS OF CONSUMER
GOODS AND SERVICES SO THERE'S A
LOT OF FLEXIBILITY EVEN WHEN YOU
THINK ABOUT YOUR LEFTIES. WITH
THE ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT SIDE
MORE THAN MAYBE SOME PEOPLE
REALIZE AS I SAID ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT REALLY STANDS OUT
WITH THE I FD IS A REALLY IT
ISN'T ABOUT THE. THE WHERE IS
POLITICAL AGREEMENT YOU COULD
HAVE HALF YOUR CITY YOU WOULD
HAVE TO CITIES YOU CAN HAVE THE
ENTIRE COUNTY IN EVERY CITY AT
IT I MEAN JUST DEPENDS ON ON
POLITICAL AGREEMENT.
THERE IS A WRINKLE THOUGH IF
THE E. IFT ISSUES ARM PONCE
THERE HAVE TO BE A FIFTY FIVE
PERCENT VOTE.
THE THEY HAVE A LITTLE MORE
FLEXIBILITY BEYOND BONDS BUT
THAT THAT IS SOMETHING THAT
CONSTRAINS THE WHERE. IS THE
VOTE REQUIREMENT.
NOW.
THERE SAID IT DIFFERENT
GUBERNATORIAL CANDIDATES AND
OTHERS HAVE BEEN TALKING ABOUT
HEY LET'S WE WILL LET'S TRY TO
BRING BACK REDEVELOPMENT.
WILL KOREA IS REDEVELOPMENT NOW
IT MAY NOT BE EXACTLY WHAT
PEOPLE ARE.
WANT HER MAYBE THEY WANT TO
CHANGE IT BUT IN TERMS OF THE
POWERS OF REDEVELOPMENT THEY'RE
ALL THERE THEY'RE ALL IN IN THE
CREEL LAW.
THE OUR ABILITY TO.
ISSUE DEBT OF WHAT WITHOUT
REQUIRING A PUBLIC VOTE IT'S
THEIR.
IMMINENT DOMAIN TO DO WHAT
ASSEMBLY IT'S THERE SO THE
POWERS A REDEVELOPMENT OR THEIR.
BUT ALSO THERE WERE SOME
ADDITIONAL PROVISIONS THAT WERE
INSERTED INTO LAW TO TRY TO.
IMPROVE THE BALANCE BETWEEN
THOSE AFFECTED IN THE COMMUNITY
ON BY BY THIS TOOL IT AND THOSE
IN CHARGE AND AND MEET MAYBE
THERE NEEDS TO BE SOME YOU KNOW.
IMPROVEMENT TO THE LAW TO MAKE
IT MAYBE A LITTLE MORE FLEXIBLE
BUT BUT BUT WHEN YOU'RE LOOKING
AT RDA AUTHORITY THERE'S A LOT
TO BUILD ON. A IN THAT LAW
THERE'S ALSO A TWENTY FIVE
PERCENT ON HOUSING SET ASIDE A
IT WITH A LOT OF THE SAME
CONDITIONS ARE THAT REQUIRE THAT
APPLIED TO RDAS.
THIS ARE AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
AUTHORITY A LAW THAT WENT
THROUGH LAST YEAR I THINK IT'S
GOING TO BE A VERY FLEXIBLE TOOL
I MEAN I THINK IT'S IT'S UP IT'S
GOT A NUMBER AND I KNOW THERE.
WAS GOING TO BE A SPEAKER ON
THAT BUT I DO THINK OF THEIR
SOME THINGS TO. TO WORK WITH IN
IN THAT LAW.
THE.
THAT MISTER BLOOM SO FIFTEEN
SIXTY EIGHT WHICH IS REALLY A AN
OFFSHOOT OF THE I FD LAW. OF IT
SAYS IF YOU CAN GET YOU CAN
ACCESS SALES TAX GROWTH AS PART
OF ANY IFT. BUT YOU HAVE TO EAT
TWENTY PERCENT HOUSE TO GO FOR
HOUSING AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
YOU ARE YOU CAN ONLY SPEND IT
IN AN INFILL AREA AND YOUR
ENTIRE E. I. F. DE HOUSE TO BE
COTERMINOUS WITH THE BOUNDARIES
OF YOUR OF YOUR CITY AND. BACK
TO WHAT I SAID ABOUT THE FIFTY
FIVE PERCENT VOTE AND THINGS
LIKE THAT THAT MAY NOT ALWAYS
HAPPEN IN TERMS OF THE
COTERMINOUS.
BUT IT IS SOMETHING THAT I'M
SURE PEOPLE ARE BEGINNING TO
EXPLORE THERE'S A COUPLE OTHER
THINGS ON THE SHELF ARE THERE IN
THE LAW.
ANNEXATIONS BETWEEN CITIES AND
COUNTIES ESPECIALLY OF
DISADVANTAGED AREAS ONE OF THE
CHALLENGES WHEN CITIES LOOK TO
IT.
ANNEXING AREA IS THE
DETERIORATED INFRASTRUCTURE HOW
YOU GONNA CLEAN THIS UP THERE'S
A OF A BILL IN PLACE THAT ALLOWS
A CITY AND COUNTY AS PART OF THE
LAUGH CHO PROCESS. TO AGREE TO A
TAX INCREMENT FINANCING
MECHANISM TO FIX THE
INFRASTRUCTURE.
SO THOSE ARE SOME THAT'S
ANOTHER LAW I THINK THAT WILL
HOPEFULLY BE BUILT ON IN THE
FUTURE. HOW THERE'S A COUPLE OF
OTHER THERE'S A SEAPORT AND
MILITARY I INFRASTRUCTURE LOS
WELL?
WHILE WE'RE TALKING ABOUT.
TOOLS I I WANT TO POINT OUT
THERE SOME OTHER TOOLS OUT THERE
IN THE LAW.
YOU KNOW CALIFORNIA COMPETES A
IT'S A THROUGH GOBIZ THERE'S A
NUMBER OF TAX CREDITS ALLOCATED
ON VIA COMMUTE OUT STATE
PROGRAM.
THAT THERE WAS.
THE ENTERPRISE ZONE PROGRAM
WHICH ALSO USED TO EXIST WAS
STATE APPROVED FORTY TWO SOUNDS
TARGETED TOWARD TRYING TO.
TO GET JOBS INTO A COMMUNITIES
THAT HAVE A LOT OF UNEMPLOYMENT
OF THAT THAT PROGRAM NO LONGER
EXISTS THE HIRING TAX CREDIT
WHICH.
SORT OF REPLACED IT HAS BEEN
REALLY UNDER UTILIZE I THINK
THERE COULD BE SOME IMPROVEMENTS
THERE THERE'S A NUMBER OF OTHER.
CREDITS.
MISTER.
OR OUT NOW SENATOR DODD AND
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRAZIER CARRIED A
BILL A. B..
IT NO SIX COUPLE YEARS AGO
PROVIDE SOME FLEXIBILITY TO
EXISTING CITIES AND COUNTIES IN
TERMS OF OF OF DOING SOME
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT.
IT WILL BE INTERESTING TO SEE
HOW THAT MOVES FORWARD. HARM IT
IS SO I KNOW THERE ARE SOME
QUESTIONS ABOUT WELL OKAY WE'VE
GOT ALL THESE TOOLS AND AND.
OKAY OR SOME EXAMPLES OF WHERE
CITIES HAVE BEGUN TO USE SOME.
Y. THE USE THE MORE.
THERE IS SET THIS UP THE LOSS
TO REDEVELOP WAS PRETTY TOUGH ON
OUR CITIES ARE WE LOST MOST OF
OUR.
EXPERTS ON COMMUNITY ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT THERE'S NOT A LOT
PEOPLE LEFT IN IN CITY HALL THAT
KNOW HOW TO DO SOME OF THIS
STUFF BECAUSE IT'S IT'S
COMPLICATED. ARM A LOT OF THE
STAFF WE HAD LEFT WERE FOCUSED
FOR ABOUT A FIVE YEAR BATTLE
WITH DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
TRYING TO HANG ON TO DIFFERENT.
THINGS THAT WERE IMPORTANT IN
THEIR COMMUNITY OF LITIGATION
ALL SORTS OF THINGS AREN'T SO A
LOT OF THESE.
WHO HOPE A LOT OF CITY
OFFICIALS REALLY HAVEN'T HAD
MUCH MET MUCH BAN WITH TRULY
FOCUS ON THESE NEW TOOLS? NOW
THAT THE SORT OF THE DUST IS
SETTLING FROM THE RDA PROCESS I
THINK YOU'LL SEE MORE
COMMUNITIES LOOKING AT IT.
AND THEN I DID MENTIONS SOME
TRUST ISSUES ARE YOU KNOW THESE
THESE ARE TOOLS ARE REALLY
LOOKING AT MAYBE ARE A FORTY
FIVE YEAR INVESTMENT AND AND IF
THE CITY'S GONNA PUT ITS
RESOURCES INTO SOMETHING FOR THE
LONG HAUL. BUT THEY REALLY DON'T
WANT THE RULES CHANGED ON AND.
A LOT BECAUSE IT JUST IT IT WAS
SO I THINK AS WE WORK ON THIS I
THINK UNDERSTAND THAT THAT THERE
HAS TO BE A LITTLE MORE.
.
WE'RE MORE OF A PARTNERSHIP THAT
THAT IF YOU EMBARK IN INTRO TO
USE ONE OF THESE TOOLS THAT THE
RULES ARE GONNA BE RADICALLY
CHANGED ON YOU.
HALFWAY INTO THAT PROCESS OR
OTHER THINGS GOING ON WITH
CITIES ARM OR THERE'S THAT WHILE
THE STATE BUDGET IS DOING BETTER
THAN A LOT OF OUR CITIES OUR
TIMES ARE NOT SO GOOD. ON A LOT
OF OUR CITIES HAVEN'T REALLY
REBOUNDED IN TERMS OF STAFFING
SINCE THE RECESSION THEY REALLY
HAVEN'T REFILL THOSE JOBS.
YOU'VE ALL READ ABOUT SOME OF
THE PENSION.
CHALLENGES OF MANY OF OUR
COMMUNITIES ARE FACING.
THAT'S KINDA TIGHTENING UP ON
ON A ON A FLEXIBILITY OF
EXISTING REVENUE.
SALES TAX.
DIFFERENT CHANGES INTERNET
ECONOMY MARKET CHANGES OR OR
KIND OF CHANGING WHERE THOSE
DOLLARS GO. PROPERTY TAX REALLY
HASN'T REBOUNDED ARE IN A LOT OF
COMMUNITIES I WAS WORKING WITH
ON.
AS A ANALYSTS FROM C. SOCK ON A
PRESENTATION WE WERE SUPPOSED TO
GIVE LATER THIS WEEK.
THEY HAVE A PRESENTATION FROM
C. SECOND SEVENTY EIGHT PERCENT
OF COUNTIES THE PROPERTY TAX
REALLY HASN'T REBOUNDED SENSE
THAT THAT THE HEIGHTS OF OF OF.
THE THE PRIOR ON A IN TWO
THOUSAND AND EIGHT SO WELLS IN
SOME COUNTIES IN SOME AREAS THE
STATE ECONOMY IS GOING REALLY
WELL THAT DOESN'T REALLY SPEAK
TO A LOT OF OTHER SITUATIONS
GOING ON. A IN THE STATE THERE'S
A COUPLE OF.
BALLOT MEASURES OUT OUTSIDE OF
THIS BUILDING THAT IF THEY WENT
THROUGH CAN EVEN LIMIT OUR
ABILITY.
ARE EVEN MORE.
THE OTHER THING GOING ON WITH
WITH CITIES WHEN LOOK AT THESE
TOOLS IS WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE
AMOUNT OF. OF WHAT'S THE
PERCENTAGE OF THE SALES ARE A
PART OF THE THE PROPERTY TAX
THAT THE ARMED COMMUNITY GETS
THERE'S A LOT OF CITIES MAY GET
FIVE TEN PERCENT FIFTEEN
PERCENT.
SO IF THAT'S ALL YOU'VE GOT YOU
KNOW IT'S GOING TO TAKE YOU ALL
VERY LONG TIME BEFORE YOU OFTEN
OF FINANCIAL LIFT TO GET
ANYTHING DONE SO.
OTHER YOU KNOW IT IT IN LESS
YOU CAN REALLY PARTNER WITH
ANOTHER ENTITY.
THAT'S ALSO A A DETERRENT.
AND SAW IT IN THE END I THINK
WE'LL PROBABLY HEAR FROM SOME OF
THE COUNTIES AND SPECIAL
DISTRICTS A LITTLE BIT LATER
THEY'VE GOT THEIR OWN MISSIONS
THEY'VE GOT THEIR OWN CHALLENGES
AND OBLIGATIONS.
AND AND THEY'RE GONNA BE CAREFUL
AT AS TO WHAT THE INVEST IN IT
IT IN WHEN IT COMES TO I THINK
THERE'S GOING TO BE A DIFFERENCE
WE'RE GONNA SEE BETWEEN. THE I
F. DE WHICH ALLOWS YOU TO CUT IT
AS I SAID THE WHERE DOES IT
REALLY MATTER ITS POLITICAL
AGREEMENT IT COULD BE ONE
INFRASTRUCTURE ISSUE OR
SOMETHING MORE COMPLEX.
I SEE MAYBE MORE PARTNERSHIP
OPPORTUNITIES BETWEEN CITIES AND
COUNTIES AND SPECIAL DISTRICTS
ON ON SOME E. I. F. DE
INFRASTRUCTURE TYPE THINGS. IT'S
HARDER FOR ME TO SEE.
COUNTIES AND SPECIAL DISTRICTS.
YEAH IT WOULD YOU KNOW WORKING
ON FIXING DOWNTOWN I MEAN THAT
THAT WAS THE TRADITIONAL
REDEVELOPMENT. ARM.
WHAT ARE THE OPPORTUNITIES GOING
FORWARD THERE'S A?
WITH ANY OF THESE NEW TOOLS YOU
NOW HAVE TO USE
SEE IF YOU CAN FIND COMMON
GROUND WITH THE COUNTY SEE IF
YOU CAN FIND. COMMON GROUND WITH
SPECIAL DISTRICT. I THINK WE'RE
GOING FORWARD WE LIKE TO SEE
WHERE WE COULD FIND COMMON
GROUND WITH THE STATE. AND WHAT
ARE THOSE AREAS THAT THAT WE
THINK THERE'S COMMON GROUND
BETWEEN CITIES AND WHAT WE DO AS
SORT OF THE URBAN CORES OF THE
STATE AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
DISADVANTAGED AREAS TRANSITORY
DEVELOPMENT CARBON REDUCTION
INFRASTRUCTURE ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT.
IN ALSO SCHOOLS BUT WHEN YOU
THINK ABOUT ON A SMART GROWTH
INFILL DEVELOPMENT ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT'S ALWAYS WAS
FORGOTTEN EVEN IN THE OLD
REDEVELOPMENT TOOL WAS THE
QUALITY OF SCHOOLS BUT THEY WERE
KIND OF IN A DIFFERENT SILO. SO
IS I THINK AS WE GO FORWARD WITH
THESE NEW TOOLS IS MAKING SURE
THAT WHATEVER WE'RE DOING A
HAVING A REALLY GOOD QUALITY
SCHOOL IS GOING TO BE A KEY TO
KIND OF AN INFILL STRATEGY
BECAUSE. IT REALLY BECOMES A
MAGNET TO.
TO TEQUILA TO ATTRACT AND
RETAIN.
INDIVIDUALS TO AND FAMILIES TO
LIVE IN THOSE AREAS SO THE
RECOMMENDATIONS IS I THINK
YOU'VE GOT A NUMBER OF REALLY
GOOD THINGS. THAT THAT ARE OUT
THERE THEY CAN BE IMPROVED THESE
TOLLS KOREA YA THEY CAN BE
IMPROVED. BUT LOOK LOOK FOR WAYS
TO CONDUCT YOU DON'T NECESSARILY
HAVE TO HELP TO HAVE A BRAND NEW
TOOL YOU CAN BUILD OFF SOME OF
THESE THINGS BECAUSE I THINK
THERE'S A LOT OF FLEXIBILITY.
ON THE OTHER THING IS THE GAME
CHANGER IN IS GOING TO BE.
WHETHER OR NOT THE STATE IS
WILLING TO OPEN UP. A DISCUSSION
OF ACCESSING THE SCHOOL SHARE
ALL ON PROJECTS WHERE THEY WILL
WHERE THERE'S COMMON GROUND IF
IT'S AN INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECT
OF ITS TOT PROJECT OF ITS
AFFORDABLE HOUSING WHERE THE
AREAS OF COMMON GROUND. THE LET
JUSTICE WE TALK AND TALK TO A
COUNTY AND THE COUNTY
SUPERVISORS OR THE SPECIAL
DISTRICT BOARD CAN MAKE UP THEIR
OWN DECISIONS ABOUT WHAT THEIR
PRIORITIES ARE AND WHETHER AND
INVESTMENT IS WORTH IT WOULD
LIKE TO FIGURE OUT SOME WAY THAT
WE CAN HAVE THAT CONVERSATION
WITH. SOME ENTITY AT THE STATE
LEVEL STRATEGIC GROWTH COUNCIL
IBEC SOME ENTITY WHERE IT WAS
UNDER SOME PARAMETERS WE CAN
MAYBE GET BACK TO SOMETHING
CLOSE TO THE OLD A CONCENTRATED
FINANCIAL LEFT. BEGIN WHAT'S
GONNA BE DIFFERENT IT'S GONNA BE
ON SOMETHING WE ALL AGREE ON
RATHER THAN THIS ARE WE DO
SOMETHING AND PEOPLE CAN DEBATE
WHETHER IT'S GOOD OR BAD. THOSE
ARE MY COMMENTS HAPPY ANSWER
QUESTIONS.
GREAT THANK YOU AT MISS KERRIGAN
I APPRECIATE VERY MUCH THAT THE
SUMMARY.
I'VE A QUESTION REALLY MORE TO
THE OTHER PANELISTS BUT.
THERE WAS ONCE THE ONE THING I
JUST WANT TO MENTION FROM WHAT I
UNDERSTAND. FOR E. IFT SINCE TWO
THOUSAND FOURTEEN ONLY A HANDFUL
OF CITIES HAVE ACTUALLY FORM
THESE IN. THE CITY'S UNAWARE OF
OUR WEST SACRAMENTO LAVERNE AND
SAN DIEGO AND THEN FOR CREA.
SINCE ITS INCEPTION IN TWENTY
FIFTEEN NO CITIES HAVE TAKEN
ADVANTAGE OF THAT.
AND THEN THE OTHER TWO LAWS AJ'S
IN THE FIFTIES.
THEY WERE BOTH OF FOR LAST
YEAR'S SO THAT THE JURY IS STILL
OUT. ARM I KNOW DAN YOU YOU LAID
OUT SO THE REASONS WHY THIS
HASN'T HAPPENED BUT I WOULD
LOVE.
AND LET'S SEE IF ANYTHING ELSE
TO ADD HERE WITH THE OTHER
PANELISTS JUST WHAT YOU THINK
ARE THE BARRIERS FOR WHY THIS
HASN'T HAPPENED I HAVE WONDERED
FOR EXAMPLE IF THE.
THE NEW SYSTEMS ARE SET UP ARE
TOO COMPLICATED. IF THE LACK OF
THE SCHOOL SHARE HOW MUCH WHAT
IMPACT THAT HAS HAD.
I HAD NOT HEARD THE THE THE
ISSUE OF OF STAFFING AND SORT
TECHNICAL EXPERTISE BUT
OBVIOUSLY THAT THAT MUST BE AN
ISSUE BUT. JUST LOVE TO
UNDERSTAND MORE WHAT HAS BEEN.
WHAT IS BEEN THE REASON WHY
THESE POSTS REDEVELOPMENT TOOLS
HAVE NOT REALLY SEEN THAT THE
PICKUP AND I KNOW DAD YOU SPENT?
ABOUT SOME GOOD TIME EXPLAINING
THAT BUT BUT WHAT I'M REALLY FOR
CERTAINLY WANT ONE QUICK
RESPONSE ARE I MEAN.
BUT PART OF IT IS ALL THE
THINGS I SAID.
BUT.
I DO THINK THAT THOUGH THE
SCHOOL SHARE IS IS IS A KEY
INGREDIENT. AND ARM I REALLY
THINK THAT THAT WOULD BE THAT
THE GAME CHANGER IN IN TERMS OF
GETTING INTO SOME OF THESE TOOLS
ALL THE OTHER THING IS. IT TAKES
AWHILE IF IF IT IS A CITY IS
EXPECTED TO GO TALK TO THE
COUNTY. TALK TO A SPECIAL
DISTRICT TRY TO FIGURE OUT IF
THERE'S AGREEMENT THAT CAN TAKE
A WHILE TALK TO YOUR COMMUNITY
SO SO EVEN THOSE WHAT THESE LAWS
ARE YOU KNOW MAYBE A COUPLE
YEARS OLD. THAT PROCESS THE OF
COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT AND TRYING
TO SEE IF THERE'S COMMON GROUND
TAKES A WHILE THERE'S A LOT WELL
THERE'S TWO OR THREE MAYBE
FORMED THERE'S A LOT OF THINGS
UNDER EXPLORATION BUT BUT I DO
THINK IT WILL TAKE AWHILE. ARE
EVEN FOR EVEN IF ALL IT EVEN IF
THE WILL WAS THERE BECAUSE I I
THINK THIS REQUIRES MORE UP
FRONT COOPERATIVE DISCUSSIONS
THAT MAYBE OTHER TOOL WHICH YOU
JUST FOLLOWED A STATUTE.
AND ONE SUMMER THAT WOULD BE
GREAT AT SOME POINT IF YOU DON'T
HAVE THE INFORMATION TODAY I'D
LOVE TO SEE IF YOU KNOW. WHAT
CITIES AND COUNTIES ARE ENGAGING
AYE ONGOING CONVERSATIONS SUCH
THAT IN A FEW YEARS MAYBE OTHERS
WILL TAKE ADVANTAGE OF FOUGHT
YEAH I HAVE TO EASE OUR CREUS?
SO WE AYE. SERVED IT JUST A
GENERAL QUESTION AS WE GO
THROUGH THIS PANEL.
SO NEXT SAW WELCOME ERIC
CALDWELL AND THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR COMING HE'S THE ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT DIRECTOR FROM THE
CITY OF SAN DIEGO AND WILL THAT
YOU GET STARTED RIGHT AWAY.
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR HAVING
ME.
ARE.
A LOT OF MY COMMENTS ARE GONNA
ACCO VERY CLOSELY THAT THE
COMMENTS THAT.
DAN JUST MADE AS IT RELATES TO.
MOST SPECIFICALLY THE EF I D.
AND THE IMPLEMENTATION AND SEEN
DIEGO WHY WE CHOSE TO USE IT.
WHY WE'VE CHOSEN TO USE IT AND
JUST ONE SPECIFIC AREA AND OF
COURSE I AM HAPPY TO SPEAK TO
SOME OF THE ISSUES?
RELATED TO CREATE AS WELL I
THINK WOULD DAM DID AN EXCELLENT
JOB OF SUMMARIZING IS THAT WITH
THE LANDSCAPE IN TERMS OF
COMMUNITY AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT POSED DISSOLUTION OF
REDEVELOPMENT.
AFTER WE.
COMMUNITY AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPERS WHAT THROUGH THE
STAGES OF GRIEF WHAT THE END OF
REDEVELOPMENT IT REALLY FORCED
US TO BE MORE CREATIVE. AND MORE
DELIBERATE AND TO WHAT I LIKE TO
CALL STACK
DIFFERENT PROGRAMS AND TOOLS WAS
NO LONGER ONE TOOL IN THE
TOOLBOX THAT WE COULD GO TO. AND
TIME AFTER TIME AGAIN USE IT AS
A MULTI TOOL TO SOLVE A WIDE
ARRAY OF PROBLEMS
NOW REQUIRES YOU TO LOOK AT THE
SPECIFIC PROBLEM THAT YOU'RE
TRYING TO SOLVE. AND THEN LATER
MULTIPLE TOOLS THAT THE STATE
PROVIDES THAT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT PROVIDES IN
LEVERAGING OUR CBG DOLLARS AND
LOOKING AT. HOW WE LEVERAGE JE
LOCAL INCENTIVES MANY
JURISDICTIONS INCLUDING THE CITY
OF SAN DIEGO HAVE CREATED NEW
INCENTIVE PROGRAMS AND LOAN
PROGRAMS
ALL FOCUSED ON CREW REBUILDING
THE ECONOMIC AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT TOOL BOX?
INTO SOMETHING THAT IS
MEANINGFUL AND USEFUL.
AS IT RELATES TO OUR E. FID
IMPLEMENTATION AND WE CREATED
OUR YOU HAVE ID AND JULY OF
TWENTY SEVENTEEN WE EXPECT THE
FIRST TEE I TAX INCREMENT
DOLLARS TO FLOW INTO THE CITY.
IN JULY OF THIS YEAR WERE
EXPECTING ABOUT SIX HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS OVER THE NEXT
FIVE YEARS THAT RAMP UP TO ABOUT
FIVE MILLION.
WE ARE USING IF ID'S AND WERE
ACTUALLY VERY EXCITED ABOUT THIS
TOOL. BUT WE'RE USING IT AS A
AYE I ACTUALLY WROTE THIS DOWN.
WOULD DAM CALLED STRATEGIC
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS OR
SURGICAL INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS
AND THAT'S VERY MUCH OF THE WAY
THAT WE'RE LOOKING AT.
SO FOR US THERE'S A COMMUNITY
ALL TIME MESA IN SAN DIEGO. JUST
RIGHT ALONG THE BORDER LARGE
AMOUNT OF UNDER DEVELOPED
INDUSTRIAL LAND.
WE TOOK FIVE HUNDRED AND TEN
ACRES OF THAT LAND AND PUT IT
INTO A E. F. I. D..
AND WERE ESSENTIALLY FUNDING
PUBLIC INFRASTRUCTURE THAT WILL
MAKE THAT COMMUNITY A BETTER
PLACE IN WHICH TO LIVE BETTER
PLACE IN WHICH AND VAST. BUT
IT'S ALL PUBLIC INFRASTRUCTURE.
.
IT IT'S I WOULD SAY THE DEEP.
PRINCIPLE CHALLENGE FOR US WOULD
BE FID.
AND WHY IT WORKED IN THAT
LOCATION BUT NOT AND OTHER
PLACES IN THE CITIES BECAUSE THE
CITY.
HAD A VESTED INTEREST IN MOVING
FORWARD WITH THAT THAT
INFRASTRUCTURE ANYWAY.
IBF IDEAS A TOOL THAT
ESSENTIALLY ALLOWS US TO TAKE
OUR OWN REVENUES THAT ARE COMING
IN. AND SIPHON THEM OFF PUT THEM
INTO A BOX THAT CANNOT BE
TOUCHED.
AS THE CITY AND ENCOUNTERS
ADDITIONAL CHALLENGES IN THE
FUTURE SO THAT IS DEDICATED
TOWARDS SCHOOLS THOSE.
PROBLEMS THAT.
WE LAID OUT IN THE FORMATION.
AND THAT'S A GOOD THING.
IN THE FORMATION OF OUR IF ID WE
DID HAVE CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
COUNTY.
IN TRYING TO GET THEM TO COME TO
THE TABLE AND EVEN EXPAND THE
BORDERS OF THE DISTRICT INTO THE
UNINCORPORATED AREA WHICH
BORDERS THE AREA.
AND OF THOSE CONVERSATIONS WERE
UNSUCCESSFUL I THINK THAT THAT
IS A DEFINITIVELY APPOINT AS THE
ASSEMBLY.
THINKS ABOUT HOW TO REFORM THIS
TOOL. AND DANCE COMMENTS WERE I
THINK SPOT ON IN THE SENSE THAT.
TO THE EXTENT THAT WE CAN AGREE
I AM AND PRIORITIES THAT MAYBE
REGIONAL IN NATURE STATEWIDE IN
NATURE.
AND HOW OF THE.
BOTH MUNICIPALITIES AS WELL AS
COUNTIES AND THE STATE ALL
AGREED THAT THERE'S GOING TO BE
SOME SHARING OF REVENUE.
AND ORDERED THERE'S IT LEAST
MORE OF AN INCENTIVE.
I CAN'T TELL YOU THAT IF THE
ROLES WERE BEEN REVERSED AND THE
COUNTY CAME TO US AND SAID WE
WANT TO FOR MANY IF ID AND WE
WANT SOME OF THE CITY'S REVENUE.
FOR OUR PRIORITIES THAT ARE
ANSWER WOULD HAVE BEEN YES.
AND.
JURISDICTIONS ARE LOOKING OUT
FOR THEIR THEIR OWN INTERESTS
INTERESTS OF THEIR CONSTITUENTS
IN THEIR BUSINESSES.
BUT I CAN TELL YOU IF THERE WAS
AN INCENTIVE FOR US TO SIT DOWN
AND HAVE A CONVERSATION WHERE WE
COULD SAY LET'S THINK REGIONALLY
LET'S THINK ABOUT.
MAYBE WHAT AND AFFORDABLE
HOUSING PROJECTS OR.
BRINGING IN A LARGE EMPLOYER
AND BUILDING THE INFRASTRUCTURE
THAT THAT EMPLOYER NEEDS OR
COMPLETING ROADS AND AND SORT OF
LIKE WE ARE AND AN ALL TIME MESA
WITH THAT WOULD HAVE ON OTHER
JURISDICTIONS IN AREAS OUTSIDE
OF THE DISTRICT. I THINK THAT
THAT WOULD BE A HELPFUL THING
TO.
TO CONTEMPLATE.
I WOULD SAY.
WHEN THINKING ABOUT WHAT DOESN'T
WORK.
.
HAVE NOT HAVING ANY IF ID
DOESN'T WORK WE'RE LOOKING AT
OTHER INSTANCES OF POTENTIALLY
HOW TO USE THIS IN THE CITY OF
SAN DIEGO. WE HAVE MAJOR
EMPLOYERS THAT I I WON'T NAME
ENDS AND RIGHT NOW BUT. THAT
HAVE LOOKED AT COULD THEY USE
THIS ON THEIR CAMPUS TO
ALLEVIATE SOME OF THE TRAFFIC
ISSUES
THAT. THEIR EMPLOYEES MAY BE AND
ENCOUNTERING AS I GET OFF THE
FREEWAY AND AND AND TRY TO GET
TO WORK.
IT'S NOT A ONE STOP TOOL I THINK
WHEN WE TALKED ABOUT.
STACKING THAT'S VERY IMPORTANT
AS THE ASSEMBLY CREATES NEW
TOOLS REFINES TOOLS I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT AS DAN MENTIONED TO
MAKE SURE THAT THOSE TOOLS ARE
WORKING. IN CONCERT WITH EACH
OTHER THAT CITIES HAVE THE
ABILITY TO TAILOR THEIR TOOLS.
AND LEVERAGE FEDERL DOLLARS TO
WORK IN CONCERT WITH THESE
TOOLS.
I CAN TELL YOU WHAT DOES WORK
WITH THE F. ID IS THAT.
THIS IS DEFINITELY A TOOL THAT
GIVES WHAT I CALL SUB LOCAL
CONTROL.
IT IS GIVING AN EMPOWERING
COMMUNITIES WERE SMALLER
PORTIONS WITHIN A COMMUNITY.
IT LEAST IN THE IN SAN DIEGO'S
IMPLEMENTATION INSTANCE THE
ABILITY TO SET A PATH WHERE
CERTAIN PROJECTS HAVE A
DEFINITIVE SOURCE OF FUNDING.
INTO THE FUTURE REGARDLESS OF
HOW POLITICS MAY CHANGE
REGARDLESS OF HOW PRIORITIES
CHANGE IT GIVES US A MECHANISM
TO LOCK BOX THAT IN.
I WOULD SAY GOOD.
.
IN IN CLOSING.
WHEN WE THINK ABOUT THE F. ID
AGAIN IT IS A VERY SPECIAL
SURGICAL TOOL. IT IS A GOOD TOOL
I THINK.
GIVING INCENTIVES TO
MUNICIPALITIES IN THE COUNTY AND
OPENING THE DOOR FOR A
CONVERSATION WITH THE STATE IS
SOMETHING THAT WOULD GREATLY
ALLOWS TO USE THAT TOOL EVEN
MORE. WHEN.
.
WE WERE TALKING ABOUT CREE IRON
Y. THE CITY HAS AND USE CREA
THAT WAS A TOOL THAT WE WE DID
AN EXTENSIVE STUDY IN THE LATTER
PART OF LAST YEAR. LOOKING AT
POTENTIAL USING THAT TOOL NOTS
MEDLEY IT IT. WAS AN ISSUE OF.
TAKING FUNDS JUST CITY FUNDS
AND.
PRESUMING THAT WE COULDN'T GET
TO AN AGREEMENT WHAT ARE COUNTY
IT WOULD JUST LOCK BOX ARE FUNDS
AND IN THAT CASE YOU HAVE A MORE
COMPLEX GOVERNMENT STRUCTURE.
THAT ESSENTIALLY WOULD BE TAKING
CITY FUNDS FOR CITY PRIORITIES
AND TURNING THEM OVER TO A
GOVERNMENT STRUCTURE THAT IS
LARGELY OUT OF OUR CONTROL.
SO IN CLOSING I.
HAPPY TO ANSWER ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS HAPPY TO BE HERE AND
ENTHUSIASTIC THAT THE COMMITTEE
IS HAVING THIS CONVERSATION
THANK YOU.
FIVE A QUICK QUESTION.
MISTER PROBLEM.
SO A WHAT RECOMMENDATIONS WOULD
YOU GIVE TO UMB OTHER CITIES
THAT ARE LOOKING IN FORMING IN
THE F. ID. AND.
HAVE ANY OF THEM REACHED OUT
FOR GUIDANCE.
WE HAVE HADOUR CONVERSATIONS
WITH A HANDFUL OF CITIES THAT
HAVE LOOKED AT YOU HAVE ID AND
KOREA. ARE GENERAL GUIDANCE TO
JURISDICTIONS ARE ARE ARE
THINKING ABOUT THIS.
ARE.
HOW IT VERY VERY EARLY ON HAVE
CONVERSATIONS WITH YOUR?
WITH YOUR COUNTY. AND SEE IF YOU
CAN'T BRING THEM TO THE TABLE I
WILL SAY THAT THE COUNTY OF SAN
DIEGO DID SIT DOWN AT THE TABLE
THERE WERE EXTENSIVE.
CONVERSATIONS ARE TO THE EXTENT
THAT YOU CAN ENGAGE OR ELECTED
OFFICIALS AND POLICYMAKERS IN
THOSE CONVERSATIONS VERY EARLY
ON I THINK IS ALSO SOMETHING
THAT'S ADVANTAGEOUS TO DO. BUT.
YOU KNOW TO THE EXTENT THAT YOU
CAN BUILD THE CONCEPT WITH
ANOTHER JURISDICTION AND PARTNER
WITH THEM THE TOOL IS GOING TO
BE MORE POWERFUL. I WILL SAY A
AND IN CONTRAST TO CREA THERE
ARE INSTANCES.
TIME MESA BEING WORN AND AND
POTENTIALLY OTHERS IN THE CITY
WHERE EVEN WITHOUT USING ANOTHER
JURISDICTIONS FUNDING. AND IF
AIDID DOES MAKE SENSE SO FINDING
THOSE USE CASES REALLY ENGAGING
CONSULTANTS TO HELP YOU LOOK AT
WATER WHAT'S THE LONG TERM
GOVERNMENTS. LOOK LIKE FOR THE
DISTRICT HOW MUCH TAX INCREMENT
ARE YOU GOING TO BRING IN. AND
THEN REALLY ASKING YOURSELF
AGAIN BECAUSE MANY OF THESE.
ATTRIBUTES OF ANY OF ID AND TO
SOME EXTENT CREA YOU CAN ALREADY
DO USING EXISTING LOCAL
AUTHORITIES IS THIS REALLY THE
RIGHT TOOL FOR YOU.
THANK YOU. FOR.
MISTER GLORIA NOW BUT COMMENTS.
DATE YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND YOU
MY MAGIC I WAS AND WHAT THE
SETTING GET BY WITHOUT IT
CHATTING AND I I OF THE CITY.
OUR CHAIRWOMAN OF ASKED THE
QUESTION THAT I WAS INTERESTED
NASCENT MISTER KALRA BUT WANTED
JUST COMMENCE MY COLLEAGUES A
BECAUSE IT.
MAZING PART OF THE CITY TEAM
DOWN THERE AND IS DEATHLY GREAT
RESOURCE FOR LUCKY TO HAVE A
MEANS HAD EXPERIENCE IN THE
BUSINESS.
IN THE BUILDING.
AS WELL AS AT THE LOCAL LEVEL.
AND I KNOW JUST ATHLETES ALL
PLAYERS HAVE YOU TO THANK YOU
FOR BEING HERE TODAY PLEASE
THINK THEY'RE FAULKNER.
TO A YOU KNOW I THINK WHAT I'M
GETTING FROM BOTH YOUR
PRESENTATION FROM BANDS IS THAT.
AT ALL TO SUBMIT MY MY BIAS
MAYBE I'M TOO OLD SCHOOL AND
THINK THAT RDA WAS EVERYTHING
THERE WAS REMEMBER THOSE GOOD
OLD DAYS WHEN I'M HEARING IS THE
US IN THESE OTHER TOOLS ARE AS
INEFFECTIVE.
AS I THOUGHT THEM TO BE IN GIVE
ME THAT'S MY OWN PERSONAL BIAS
HAVING REMEMBERED WHAT IT IS TO
HAVE MILLIONS AND MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS OF TAX INCREMENT.
BY TAKING AWAY THAT MAYBE THIS
IS BETTER AND PERHAPS.
THE LACK OF WHAT I SEE IS ACTUAL
RESULTS IS PRACTICE THESE ARE
STILL IN THEIR INFANCY IS THAT A
FAIR TAKE AWAY FROM YOUR
COMMENTS.
I WOULD SAY.
JUST TO GREAT EXTENT YES WE ARE
STILL FIGURING OUT HOW THESE
TOOLS WORK WHERE THEY WORK
PASSED.
ANY DAN AS AS.
I THINK EVERYONE LOOKED AT
REDEVELOPMENT AS IF WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT THE ECONOMIC AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT TOOL
CHEST.
IT WAS THE POWER SAW YOU KNOW
THAT COULD CUT THROUGH ANYTHING.
AND WHAT WE'VE BEEN LEFT WORK
SINCE THE DISSOLUTION OF
REDEVELOPMENT ARE SOME REALLY
FINE HAND TOOLS.
YOU CAN STILL ACCOMPLISH IT BUT
NOW YOU MIGHT NEED TO USE TWO OR
THREE DIFFERENT TOOLS FOR
EXAMPLE ON AFFORDABLE HOUSING. I
WOULD WE'D JANET MENTIONED IN
HIS PRESENTATION THAT ASSEMBLAGE
YOU KNOW USING EMINENT DOMAIN
ASSEMBLING PROPERTIES BEING ABLE
TO SIT ON THOSE PROPERTIES WHILE
YOU. YOU ASSEMBLE ADDITIONAL
PARCELS AND THEN BRING IT
TOGETHER AND OFFER IT TO A
ULTIMATELY BILL THAT AFFORDABLE
HOUSING WITH SOME DEGREE OF
DISCOUNT OR FAVORABLE TERMS? IT
YOU CAN'T REALLY DO THAT UNDER
ANY IF ID YOU CAN BUILDING
UNDERLYING INFRASTRUCTURE YOU
CAN. WORK ON AN EXISTING PROJECT
WHEN I TALK TO AFFORDABLE
HOUSING DEVELOPERS TODAY
ASSEMBLAGES THE NUMBER ONE
ISSUE.
THAT THEY'RE FACING IN SAN
DIEGO.
I LOVE THE ANALOGY SO THANK YOU
FOR HAVING. CONVERTED TO THAT
FAIRLY QUICKLY ARM MAYBE JUST A
FOLLOW UP IN AND I REALIZE THIS
MAY NOT BE AS A BENEFICIAL TO MY
COLLEAGUES ARE GOING UP HIS
FAVOR A FAMILIAR WITH A TEN MESA
OTHER AFTER YESTERDAY PUBLIC ARE
FAIRLY WELL FAMILIAR AT THIS
POINT.
DIFFICULT INFRASTRUCTURE
PROJECT.
AIR KEY TALK ABOUT WHAT'S BEING
BUILT WITH THIS WAS NO THAT WAS
ABOUT THE TRUMP BORDER WALL
THING INSIDE OUT. INSIDE JOKE
COMEDY ROUTINE.
ERIC KNOWS THIS YET EIGHT YEARS
OF IT WITH ME AT. ALL
GITA WHICH A BUILDING DOWN AND I
GIVE ME A SENSE OF WHAT YOU'RE
ABLE TO ACCOMPLISH WITH THE EF
ID ON ATTENDANCE.
SO THIS WAS AN AREA THAT HAD
HISTORICALLY BEEN UNDER INVESTED
AS IT RELATES TO CITY
INFRASTRUCTURE SO LOOKING AT OUR
PUBLIC FACILITIES FINANCING
PLAN.
FOR THAT PARTICULAR COMMUNITY IS
ESSENTIALLY WHAT THAT YOU HAVE
IDEAS FINANCING SO NO LONGER
WILL WE BE ABLE TO NOT FINANCE
THOSE THINGS WE HAVE A DEDICATED
REVENUE SOURCE. TO BUILD ROADS
AND SEWERS AND INFRASTRUCTURE
AREN'T CHEAP TO YOUR POINT THIS
AREA BEING ALONG THE US MEXICO
BORDER.
IT IS FIVE HUNDRED TEN ACRES OF
SOME OF THE.
LAST REMAINING PARCELS WHERE YOU
CAN BILLS INDUSTRIAL IN THE CITY
OF SAN DIEGO.
AND SOME OF IT IS RAW LAND A LOT
OF IT IS VACANT.
SOME OF IT WAS JUST RECENTLY
ZONE FOR THE VERY FIRST TIME SO
BUILDING UP TO SEWER IN THE
INFRASTRUCTURE IS SOMETHING THAT
IS GREATLY NEEDED. AND THAT'S
PRINCIPLE REASON THESE FUNDS FOR
LIVE SUPER HELPFUL BECAUSE AND I
THINK IT AND GET IN THE OLD DAYS
ON PROJECT AREA YOU'RE THINKING
ABOUT WHAT PROJECT WHAT PARK
WHATEVER YOU TRY TO BUILD.
MYSTIFICATION BILLION UP OF
FACILITIES.
PUBLIC FACILITIES THAT IN
MEMORY SERVES YOU COULDN'T THERE
CERTAIN ROADS WE COULDN'T
COMPLETE THERE'S A LOT OF
DRAINAGE AND OTHER ISSUES THAT
RIGHT THAT WERE BARRIERS TO
PRIVATE SECTOR DEVELOPMENT SO.
THAT A IF ID DELIVERS HIS
INFRASTRUCTURE THING YOUR HOPE
IS THAT BECAUSE OF THIS PRIME
LOCATION IN ITS IN ITS POTENTIAL
USE THAT TO GET THE PRIVATE
SECTOR DEVELOPMENT THAT'S WORTHY
OF THE STATE OF THAT. THE
COMMUNITIES INVESTMENT IN THIS
DISTRICT CRAP.
BOB WELL AGAIN I WOULD JUST
MENTION TO BOTH MY COLLEAGUES TO
CHAIR THIS COMMITTEE I MEAN
THEY'RE A MISSED CALL IS A
WONDERFUL RESOURCE THANK YOU FOR
TRAVELING UP HERE.
I THINK I I IT'S IT'S IT'S
HELPFUL HERE AGAIN OF THIS MAY
BE MORE USEFUL THAN I THOUGHT IT
WAS.
I HAVE ONE FOLLOW UP QUESTION
AND I'M JUST.
WONDERFULLY FIXATED ON YOUR
EXAMPLE OF THE POWER TOOL A
NEVER HEARD.
EFTS DESCRIBED THAT WAY ONE OF
THE CONCERNS THAT I'VE HEARD AS
TO WHY IT HASN'T BEEN MORE
WIDELY USED IS IS JUST NOT
ENOUGH INCREMENT ORDER PUT USING
ALGAE. IT'S ONE POWER TOOL TO
TRY TO BUILD THOUSANDS OF UNITS
OF HOUSING IS JUST NOT ENOUGH.
WOULD YOU AGREE WITH THAT.
INSIEME DIEGO'S.
EXAMPLE. AND AGAIN IT DEPENDS
ON WHEN YOU LAUNCH IT IN WHERE
YOU'RE ESTABLISHING THAT BASE
YEAR BUT THAT WAS AN ISSUE AS
WE'VE LOOKED AT YOU HAVE ID
IMPLEMENTATION OTHER PARTS OF
THE CITY. SPEND EVEN MORE OF AN
ISSUE AS WE LOOKED AT CREE UP.
AND WE DID OUR ANALYSIS OF
EVERY.
CENSUS TRACT THAT WE COULD PUT
INTO A CREA AND ULTIMATELY
THAT'S WHAT WE CAME UP WITH
USING BIDS JUST OUR OWN DOLLARS
IN TERMS OF THE CITY OF SAN
DIEGO.
AT
IT IT JUST WASN'T ENOUGH NEW
INCREMENTAL JUSTIFY THE CREATION
OF THE ENTITY.
GREAT THANK YOU THAT SAID THAT'S
FOR HELP AGAIN EDGE OF HER
COLLEAGUES THE FACT THAT. NOT A
SINGLE CITY HAS FORMED A CREA
SINCE IT WAS.
STARTED IN TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN
I THINK IS A. BIT OF A FLAG
ALTHOUGH AGAIN IF YOU WERE IF IF
THE PANELS AWARE OF CITIES THAT
ARE SERIOUSLY CONSIDERING.
CREATORE I'VE HE'S BE HELPFUL
FOR US TO KNOW THAT I KNOW
WHAT'S AGO WAS LOOKING AT IT AND
I BELIEVE SALINAS WAS LOOKING AT
IT I DON'T KNOW WHERE THEY ARE
RIGHT NOW BUT I AGAIN I THINK
WHEN YOU IT IT GETS. SOME OF THE
ANALYSIS COMES BACK TO THE
FINANCIAL LEFT ISSUE AND AND.
IT AND I AYE ON THESE
CONVERSATIONS WITH OTHER TAXI
ENTITIES COUNTIES AND SPECIAL
DISTRICTS I MEAN.
IT ISN'T IT.
S. STARKLY THERE NEVER WERE SUCH
CONVERSATIONS SO THIS IS A BRAND
NEW CONVERSATION THAT'S BEING
OUT AND REMEMBER WE'RE JUST
FINISHING UP THE REDEVELOPMENT
PROCESS WHICH WAS PRETTY
CONTROVERSIAL AND THERE'S A LOT
ATTENTION SO. I THINK THERE
NEEDS TO BUILD A BIT MORE
BREATHING ROOM AT MAYBE IN THE
FUTURE A COUNTIES AND AND
SPECIAL DISTRICTS MARTZ MIGHT
START SEEING OPPORTUNITIES THAT.
BUT SOME IT IT I THINK WITH ALL
THESE TOOLS I THINK IT'S A
LITTLE EARLY THAT THEY'RE THAT
DID TAKES AWHILE TO TO SET THESE
UP IN AND GET THE BY AND.
ONE LAST QUESTION FOR HIS FATHER
I'M WHAT OTHER TOOLS ARE YOU
LOOKING AT YOU SAID BEING
STACKED.
SO WE'RE ACTUALLY LOOKING AT A
LOT OF NEW PROGRAMS THAT WE'RE
CREATING IN LOW TO MODERATE
INCOME CENSUS TRACKS USING CBG
HISTORICALLY THE CITY HAS NOT.
UTILIZE CVG FOR ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT ACTIVITY.
AND.
.
ESSENTIALLY WHAT WERE WHAT WE'RE
DOING NOW ESPECIALLY AS IT
RELATES TO BUSINESSES OR
DEVELOPMENTS WERE HAVING
SPECIFIC CONVERSATIONS WITH
DEVELOPERS AND BUSINESSES AND
ASKING ABOUT. WHAT'S WHAT'S THE
GAP AND AND HOW DO WE CLOSE THAT
GAP.
SO ON AFFORDABLE HOUSING
PROJECTS WERE ACTUALLY LOOKING
AT CAN WE USE CFD LAW.
POTENTIALLY.
PAY FOR SOME OF THE ASSEMBLAGE
WHERE WERE ESSENTIALLY ALLOWING
VERY SIMILAR TO WHAT THE PACE
FINANCING AND EXPLORE AND. USING
OUR CHARTER AUTHORITY AS A CITY
CAN WE.
ALLOW FOR THE PURCHASE OF
PROPERTY FINANCE IT USING A. CFD
BELARUS TYPES STRUCTURE AND THEN
AS SOON AS THAT PROJECT IS
COMPLETED IT'S USUALLY SOLD OFF
TO TO SOMEBODY ELSE AND AT THAT
TIME THAN THAT THAT SPECIAL
ASSESSMENTS CLEARED. SO IT'S
IT'S LOOKING A LOT OF KIND OF. I
WOULD SAY MORE INNOVATIVE AND
REALLY IF THERE WAS ANY GOOD
THAT CAME OUT OF THE DISSOLUTION
OF REDEVELOPMENT. ARM FROM MY
PROFESSIONS PERSPECTIVE THAT WAS
IT IT'S REALLY REQUIRED US TO
GET CREATIVE AND AND THINK ABOUT
WHAT CAN WE DO LOCALLY. TO SOLVE
SOME OF THESE PROBLEMS AND BE
SPECIFIC FOR SPECIFIC PROJECTS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SO WITHOUT FURTHER ADO WILL MOVE
ON TO.
MICHAEL LANE POLICY DIRECTOR
NONPROFIT HOUSING ASSOCIATION
CAL AMONG THE CALIFORNIA THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR PATIENCE.
DID YOU CAN TELL THIS IS QUITE
THE SUBJECT TORRENT NO PROBLEM
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
AND LIKE TO SPEAK TO. TIFF TOOLS
IF YOU WILL FROM THE PERSPECTIVE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN PARTICULAR
CAN ANSWER SOME YOUR QUESTIONS
AS WE GO ALONG BECAUSE I WAS
ALL.
IN MY PREPARED REMARKS ANYWAY
BUT JUST WANNA GIVE YOUR
THOUGHTS WHAT WE SEE IN THE
FIELD WILL BE THANKS WE. THINK
WORKS IN GIVING UP IN THE WORK
THAT WE'VE BEEN DOING IN THE
LEGISLATURE. WITH THE LEAGUE AND
WITH OTHERS TO TRY THAT REALLY
ENHANCE SOME OF THESE TOLD
RICHARD ABOUT TO MAKE THEM AS.
AS PRODUCTIVE AS POSSIBLE
PARTICULAR BAYER REGION WHICH WE
REPRESENT.
WHICH HAS SOME DIFFERENT KINDS
OF CHALLENGES THAT WERE TRYING
TO ADDRESS.
PARTICULAR IN TERMS OF HOUSING.
JOBS KINDS A GAPS WERE SEEN AND
THEN PATTERNS OF RESEGREGATION
EMERGING THAT WE'RE TRYING TO
ADDRESS AND GENTRIFYING AREAS
AND SO. DOES THE KIND OF THE
PERSPECTIVE THAT WILL TAKE ON
THE SCHOOL IS MOSTLY FIRST OF
ALL TALK ABOUT THE I FD LET
THANK.
IN TWENTY FOURTEEN WERE
CERTAINLY PLEASED IF THE
ADMINISTRATION CAME BACK TO
TABLE RECOGNIZE THE NEED TO
WAS THE GOOD NEWS THE BAD NEWS
IS WE WERE NEVER SURE THAT THE I
FD KIND OF.
PLACE IN IN IN THE CODE WAS THE
PLACE TO GO TOOK THAT ON. IFT IS
REALLY WERE FOR SORTS OF PUBLIC
WORKS PRO USE CALL PUBLIC WORKS
PROJECTS FLOOD CONTROL PROJECTS
FOR YOU WOULD ASSESS PROPERTY
OWNERS.
WHO ALL HAD A KIND OF A A
BENEFIT THAT THEY ARE RECEIVING
FROM THIS KIND OF INVESTMENT?
AND WAS A TWO THIRDS VOTE
REQUIREMENT SARTRE AND WE TRY TO
TO BROADEN THAT A BIT UNIT UP
WITH AN ENHANCED INFRASTRUCTURE
FINANCING JUST COMING UP YOU
KNOW APPRECIATE THAT EFFORT.
BUT IT DOES REQUIRE VOTER
APPROVAL AND SO YOU REALLY NEED
LARGE. AREAS OF LAND WE HAVE
ELEVEN REGISTERED VOTERS ARE
FEWER. AND WE HAD ONE LANDOWNER
AND WE'RE GOING TO BRING IN A
LOT OF PRIVATE INVESTMENT OVER
TIME TO REALLY BE ABLE TO PAY
OFF THOSE THOSE BONDS THAT YOU
DO ISSUE SO THAT. THE BOTTOM
LINE FOR US IT'S IT'S LONG ONE
PROCESS IN SHORT ON REVENUES
THAT YOU'RE GENERATING IN MOST
AREAS WHERE DOES WORK IN
PARTICULAR I THINK IS A MILITARY
REUSE KINDS OF A PLAN. WE WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE A LARGE OPEN SPACE
WITH ONE LANDOWNER HAVE
POTENTIALLY LOTS OF VERY.
LUCRATIVE INVESTMENT COMING IN
PARTICULAR THAT YOU CAN THEN
FUND THAT INFRASTRUCTURE KNOWING
OVER TIME THAT TAX INCREMENT IS
GOING TO BE GENERATED. BUT THERE
WAS NO LO LO MAS SET ASIDE EVEN
IN THE I FD BELIEVE IT OR NOT
AMAZINGLY ENOUGH AFTER THE
DISSOLUTION OF REDEVELOPMENT.
AND SO IT WAS BASICALLY OPTIONAL
YOU COULD DO IT OR NOT SO WE'RE
VERY DISAPPOINTED ABOUT THAT IS
THE I FD AS A TOOL.
AND SO THEN WE LOOKED AT THE
CREATES AND WE REALLY APPRECIATE
THE WORK THAT DAN AND OTHERS IN
THE CBA.
DID WITH WITH FORMER
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LUIS ALEJO WAS IT
WAS REALLY GOOD WORK ON THE
GROUND NAY KIND OF GRIND IT OUT.
I DID A YEOMAN'S JOB ON GETTING
HIS CREOSOTE UP THE LIMITS OF
THE CREE AS THOUGH.
.
AND I DON'T OF DEAD MENTION THIS
OR NOT BUT THERE REALLY TARGET
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES WITH
HIGH INDICES OF UNEMPLOYMENT AND
CRIME STATISTICS.
AND SO MANY PARTS OF OUR STATE
REALLY CAN'T BENEFIT FROM THEM
BUT WE DO APPRECIATE THE FACT
THAT THEY TOOK THE LEAD TO BUILD
A TOOL AND WORK WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION SEE WHAT THE
GOVERNOR WAS WILLING TO SIGN.
AND WE THINK THAT WAS REALLY
VALUABLE WORKS THAT'S WHY WE
CAME BACK THE NEXT YEAR WITH AB
FIFTEEN NINETY ABLE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MULLIN. TO DO THESE
HOUSING AUTHORITIES WHICH
EXPLICITLY BUILT ON THE CREATE
CONCEPT BUT THERE REALLY
TARGETED FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING
AND AFFORDABLE HOUSING RELATED
INFRASTRUCTURE. AND THAT DOESN'T
MEAN THAT WE DON'T CARE ABOUT
LARGER KIND OF CAPITAL
IMPROVEMENT PLANS THAT THE
CITY'S HABIT SEPARATELY ALSO A
TREMENDOUS NEEDS THERE. AND A
LOT OF THOSE THOSE COST BURDENS
GET SHIFTED TO NEW DEVELOPMENT.
BECAUSE THERE'S NO OTHER WAY TO
FUND THESE KIND A MAJOR
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS THAT
CITIES NEED TO UNDERTAKE THAT'S
BEEN EXACERBATED BY.
THE SLASHING OF OF THE HOME IN
CBG FUNDS AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL
THAT'S WHY EVEN MORE THAN EVER.
WE TO STRONG STATE PARTNER TO
STEPIN AND HELP US TO DO
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT BECAUSE
THE FEDS ARE NOT HERE TO HELP
AND QUITE FRANKLY IT'S GOING IN
THE OPPOSITE DIRECTION YOU KNOW
EXPECT. EVEN DEEPER CUTS TO
TEHAMA CITY BG IN TERMS OF OF
THOSE KEY TOOLS ANDFINANCING
FOR FOR INFRASTRUCTURE AND
HOUSING.
LOCALLY THOUGH SOME
JURISDICTIONS HAVE HAD THAT THE
WILL POLITICAL WILL TO STEP UP
PROGRESSIVE JURISDICTIONS TO DO
THEIR OWN INFRASTRUCTURE TAX.
AND VOTERS HAVE ACTUALLY VOTED
FOR THOSE IN OAKLAND FOR EXAMPLE
IN THE CITY OF SAN MATEO. TO TRY
TO HELP BACKFILL SOME OF THAT.
AND WHAT WE SAW ON THE PENINSULA
IN THE BAY AREA.
IS TREMENDOUS NEW COMMERCIAL
OFFICE DEVELOPMENT COMING ONLINE
SO WASN'T A QUESTION ABOUT
BLIGHT.
A PRIVATE INVESTMENTS COMING AND
THESE WERE GENTRIFYING AREAS AND
AS A LAW AND THERE'S A LOT OF OF
INDUSTRY MOVING INTO THE AREA
AND THAT'S WHERE THE JOBS
HOUSING GAP WAS GETTING WORSE
AND WORSE AND SO THE IDEA OF AB
FIFTY NINETY EIGHT WAS. WE
HARDLY GOT THIS INVESTMENT
COMING AND BOTH FOR THE
INFRASTRUCTURE AND ON AND ON THE
JOB SITE. COULD WE CAPTURE A
BILL THAT INCREMENT ONE ON THE
PENINSULA UNLIKE OTHER PARTS THE
STATE PERHAPS. HOW WE HAVE
LISTENED TO PERCENT UNEMPLOYMENT
WERE SEEN ASSESSED VALUES OF
PROPERTIES TEN PERCENT YEAR OVER
YEAR INCREASES IN ASSESSED VALUE
AND PROPERTY TAX INCREASES FOR
JURISDICTIONS?
SO THEY'RE FEELING PEER PRETTY
POSITIVE OUT THAT THE ISSUE IS
CAN WE CAPTURE SOME OF THAT FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING THAT'S WERE
ATTEMPTING TO DO. SOME OF THE
OTHER CHALLENGES THAT WE DID SEE
WE ALSO DID WORKED ON.
A BOOMERANG BILL.
WAS A MEMBER BONTA WERE SOME OF
THOSE REVENUES TO COME BACK.
FROM THE DISSOLUTION OF
REDEVELOPMENT BACK TO
JURISDICTIONS COULD YOU BOND
AGAINST THOSE REVENUES.
SANTA SITTING KIND OF SAN
FRANCISCO HAS DONE THAT MOTHER
JURISDICTION OF ACTUALLY
DEDICATED SOME OF THOSE. THOSE
LAWS ARE REVENUES COMING BACK
THE WILD WHY MANY JURISDICTIONS
HAVE NOT DONE IT DOWN KIND OF
ALLUDED TO THIS WITH THAT THEY
DO HAVE SIGNIFICANT PENSION
OBLIGATIONS THERE'D THERE'D
WRESTLING WITH AND ON GOING
ENFORCEABLE OBLIGATIONS. THAT
EXISTED PRIOR TO THEIR THEIR A
DISSOLUTION OF REDEVELOPMENT AND
BONDS IS THEY STILL NEED TO PAY
OFF BUT WE THINK THAT OVER TIME.
HAS ENFORCEABLE OBLIGATIONS ARE
PAID OFF AS WE ADDRESS THE
PENSION OBLIGATIONS THERE WILL
BE ADDITIONAL.
REVENUES ARE POTENTIALLY IF WE
HAVE THE BONDING AUTHORITY
WITHOUT GOING THROUGH YOU KNOW.
A ROOF GOAL OF OUR ECONOMY
GOLDBERG KIND OF MECHANISM. AND
JUST BE ABLE TO ISSUE DEBT
BECAUSE YOU'RE NOT INCREASING
TAXES BUT YOU'RE TAPPING INTO
SOME THOSE RESOURCES ARE COMING.
UP FROM THE PARK PRIVATE
INVESTMENT SO HAVING SAID ALL
THOSE THINGS I WOULD SAY WE DO
NEED THE LEGISLATURE STEP IN A
HELP US WORK THROUGH THE
STAKEHOLDER PROCESS. ONE THE
RESOURCES BEEN INCREMENTAL IS
ONE TO MAKE SURE HE GOT IT RIGHT
WITH DAN WITH THE CITY'S FIRST
AS WE BUILT ON THAT. AND IT HAD
A TOOL THAT WE COULD THEN TRY TO
ENGAGE THE COUNTIES ON. AT
BECAUSE THAT'S ACTUALLY
ESSENTIAL AND NOW WE THINK WE'RE
ACTUALLY SOME SIGNIFICANT CLEAN
UP THE SURE TO FIFTEEN NINETY
EIGHT WITH WAS WITH SUMMER
MULLIN AND WE HOPE THAT THE
LEAGUE WILL ONCE AGAIN BE WITH
US. WE ALSO NEED TO GET SEE SACK
INVOLVED WE GOT COUNTIES
APPROACHING US SAYING THAT WE
LIKE TO LOOK AT THESE TWO ALSO
SOME OF THE LANGUAGE WILL BE
BRINGING FORWARD. WILL BE INPUT
FROM CITIES FROM FROM COUNTIES
AND ALSO FROM BOND COUNSEL
THINGS THAT THEY'RE LOOKING AT
BECAUSE NEED TO WRITE THOSE
OPINIONS TO BE ABLE TO ISSUE
THAT THAT.
AND SO WE WANNA MAKE SURE WE
GET THAT LANGUAGE RIGHT TO BE
ABLE TO IMPLEMENT AS WE THINK
REALLY CLOSE AND NOW'S THE TIME
PARTICULAR TO TALK ABOUT AARTI
AARTI TO POINT ON EVEN.
PERHAPS HAVING THE STATE
PARTICIPATE FIRST ALL GIVEN THE
SAME PAGE WE GOT ALL THESE TOOLS
AND I GOT THIS LANGUAGE NOW. IN
IN THE CODE US MAKE SURE IT'S
CONSISTENT AND LET'S MAKE SURE%
TOLD A LOCAL JURISDICTIONS HAVE
THE FLEXIBILITY AND USER
FRIENDLY TOOLS TO BE ABLE TO
STAND THE SUB. IT IMMEDIATELY
AND ACTION ARE BILL ANOTHER
PIECE THE LANGUAGE WILL BE THAT
YOU CONNECT THE BASED YOUR COULD
ACTUALLY BE PRIOR TO THE CURRENT
FISCAL YEAR SHE COULD GO BACK. A
MAXIMUM OF FIVE YEARS SO THAT
ALL THAT GROWTH THAT WE'VE SEEN
ATTACKS OCCUR WE TRY TO CAPTURE
SOME OF THAT NOW. AND BEGIN
ISSUE THAT THAT RIGHT AWAY
WITHOUT HAVING TAKE LOANS FROM
THE CITY THAT NEED TO BE.
REPAID.
SO WE LOOK FORWARD TO THOSE
DISCUSSIONS MCCARTY TWO POINT
ALLEN WHEN IT TO BRING OUR
MEMBERS A RESOURCE EXPERIENCE TO
BEAR ON THOSE DISCUSSIONS OF
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ONE QUESTION.
TO MICHAEL MAYBE TO ALSO MISTER
CALDWELL HAVE YOU SEEN III OF
TI'S USED TO BUILD HOUSING I
KNOW IT CAN BE USED FOR HOUSING
BUT THERE'S NOT A SPECIFIC
REQUIREMENT TO.
DOESN'T SOUND LIKE THAT'S WHAT
YOU HAVE INTENDED USE IT FOR IT
SAN DIEGO.
IN IN SAN DIEGO WE ARE NOT.
AGAIN HOPE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
DEVELOPERS FINANCE HOUSING I
THINK WHERE THE IF ID FALL SHORT
IS ON THE ASSEMBLAGE PIECE WHICH
WE CAN DO AND WE ARE DOING WHAT
OURS IS IT IS A MECHANISM WHERE
WE CAN TAKE SOME OF THE.
FEES THAT WOULD HAVE BEEN
IMPOSED ON THE DEVELOPMENT AND
USE IF ID DOLLARS TO TO HELP
OFFSET THOSE BUT WE'RE WE'RE NOT
USING IT DIRECTLY YET TO BUILD
HOUSING.
AND MICHAEL WHAT DO YOU SEE WHAT
YOU NEED IS YOU HAVE TO HAVE A
LOCAL JURISDICTION TO DO AN
OVERLAY. WHERE THEY ACTUALLY
REQUIRE FOR EXAMPLE THE CONCORD
NAVAL WEAPONS STATION
REDEVELOPMENT PROJECT THE
REQUIRED TWENTY FIVE PERCENT
AFFORDABLE IN THAT BUILD OUT BUT
IF YOU DON'T HAVE A REQUIREMENT
IN THE I FD? WOULD MOST LIKELY
NOT BE USED FOR HOUSING AT ALL
FOR THE MOST PARTGOTCHA AND AND
HELP WILL SHOW YOU ABOUT TO.
MISTER MULLINS AJ.
THAT THE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
AUTHORITIES BEEN USED.
IN THE NEAR FUTURE YOU FEEL YOU
HEAR ABOUT PICK UP FROM CITIES
WE'VE HAD S.
SIX CITIES AND COUNTIES OF OUR
BEENCONTACTING US AND IN FACT
THE CLEANUP WILL SEE THIS YEAR
COMING BEFORE YOU'VE. LIKELY
BASED ON THAT INPUT AND I'D LIKE
TO USE THAT IMMEDIATELY MAYBE WE
COULD DO THAT'S PART OF THE
BUDGET PROCESS THAT COULD TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY IF YOU'RE
OPEN THAT.
THAT. I DID HAVE A CONVERSATION.
THANK YOU.
SO I LIKE ALL THE TOOLS AM NOT
AND I'M GLAD TO HEAR THAT SOME
OF THESE ARE WORKING IN THERE.
YOU KNOW IN PROGRESS.
MY CONCERN IS ON SOME OF THE
SMALL RURAL COMMUNITIES.
THAT.
I DON'T HEAR ANYTHING THIS IS A
USER NECESSARY GONNA WORK WHEN
YOU SAY STAFFING IS THAT COST.
OUR OF.
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
DEPARTMENTS ARE GONE.
SO. IF I'M LOOKING FOR SOME
SUGGESTIONS AND YOU KNOW OF ANY
SMALL COMMUNITIES THAT MIGHT BE
USING ANY THIS TOOLS CURRENTLY.
BECAUSE THE ONE THING I'VE I'VE
NOTICED MY SHORT TIME HERE. IS
ONE SIZE DOES NOT FIT ALL.
AND.
WHAT WHAT MIGHT WORK IN SAN
DIEGO MAY NOT WORK FOR A
COMMUNITY OF TEN THOUSAND? OR
SEVEN THOUSAND OR SO I'M WERE.
IT'S A SOMETHING I WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE DON'T FORGET ABOUT.
SO INELIGIBLE USED TO RURAL
COMMITTEES ASSISTANCE
CORPORATION AND YOU MAY NOTE
PROVIDES TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
SUPPORT OF THE LEGISLATURE TO
REALLY MAKE THAT A PART OF THE
SYSTEM TO BE ABLE TO PROVIDE
THAT BECAUSE YOU YOU YOU'RE
RIGHT. NOT ONLY IN IN IN LARGER
CITIES EVEN HER STRUGGLING TO
STAFFING LOTS REDEVELOPMENT IT'S
ALWAYS BEEN IT'S ALWAYS BEEN
DIFFICULT EVEN BEFORE THE.
BLOSSOMING OF ALL FOR LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS TO BE ABLE TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE SOME HE'S TOLD ME IN
THE BILL TO GET THE WORD OUT SO
THEY CAN DO THAT'S ALL WE COULD.
SUM AS INTERMEDIARIES TO PROVIDE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE WE COULD
MAKE THAT A PART OF THE PROCESS
WE DON'T NEED COMMITTEES BEHIND
I THINK THAT WOULD BE VERY. VERY
VALUABLE APPROACH LIKE TO
PROVIDE YOU SOME CONTACTS.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS FROM
COLLEAGUES.
YOU CHOI.
DON'T THINK YOU I WONDER
PROBLEM.
MON.
SEVERAL OF THE ON TOOL RUSSO IN
NEW OFF OUR REDEVELOPMENT AGENCY
I COME FROM.
ORANGE COUNTY. I WAS THE MAYOR
OR BY.
AND.
P. MAUREEN COR A A A PIECE.
I WAS SO TURNED INTO.
NOW WHICH COUNTY GRAY PARKA.
WE WILL VERY STRONGLY IN.
BOMB MAKING PROGRESS.
A WHEN USING THE.
TAX INCREMENTS.
A DEVELOPING THE PAUL GO. AND
THE.
RUG WAS SUPPORT AWAY WHEN THE
REDEVELOPMENT DIE.
SO WE HAD THE LITIGATIONS
ETCETERA.
A.
AMONG THIS.
TO DELTORA NAME SO THAT THE. E.
I. F. DE. AND THE CREE. AHA. A.
AND AND AYE F. T. OUR I AM NOT
ABOUT SOUPS I KINDA THEY JUST
TEAR.
I WONDER IF FOR ANY OF THESE.
TOURS SO.
WATER APPLY TO. A MY DISTRICT UP
PARTICULARLY UP FOR THAT. AREA
CBO IRVINE BECAUSE SELF OUR.
GENERAL.
.
IF THE INCOME.
A LEVEL.
IT MAY NOT BE. QUALIFIED BECAUSE
A LOT OF THINGS AFFORDABLE HOMES
WHAT DISADVANTAGED.
CRIMINAL RATES ETCETERA YOU KNOW
BEING THE SAFEST CITY IT MAY NOT
APPLY BUT. HOW YOU DEFINE WHERE
THE?
THAT THE PARTICULAR PRESIDED
AREA WE CAN SAY THAT THERE WAS A
BLIGHTED BECAUSE NOTHING WAS
THERE. DEFINITION Y. SAYS ENTIRE
CITY OF IRVINE WENT. ANTI COUNTY
OF ORANGE HOW WOULD YOU DEFINE
IT AND. IF SO HOW WHICH OF THESE
TOURISM MAY BE APPLICABLE TO ME.
IN OUR LISTENING TO YOU HERE AM
I WASTING IT MAY NOT BE MAKING
ANY SENSE TO US A SO THAT'S WHAT
I. WANT TO GET SOME IDEA FROM.
YEAH AND SO WE WE HAVE GOOD
FRIENDS OF THE CAN THE
COMMISSION AND ORANGE COUNTY
WHO'VE BEEN WORKING WITH ON SOME
OF THESE TOOLS I THINK I THINK
THAT THE HOUSING AUTHORITIES TO
CAN WORK FOR YOU. IT DOESN'T
REQUIRE A BLIGHT FINDING AND
ACTUALLY WE DO ALLOW YOU TO TO
FUND A RANGE PREDICT IN HIGH
COST AREAS TO GO UP TO HUNDRED
TWENTY PERCENT OF THEM I FOR
WORKFORCE HOUSING. AS WELL AS
LOWER INCOME HOUSING SO YOU CAN
ACTUALLY OF MIXED INCOME
DEVELOPMENTS THAT COULD BE
FUNDED BASED ON YOUR ARENA
ALLOCATION THAT YOU GET WHICH
ALSO GOES UP TO THE MODERN
VERSION OF WHICH TO WILLOW. CAN
BE THAT WAS THAT WAS THE THE
CREE A PLUS THAT WE EXPAND ON
THREE AB FIFTEEN NINETY EIGHT
YEAH I THINK YOU. THERE'S TOOL
TOOLS TO TOOLS ON THAT LIST.
ONE IS E. IFT THERE IS NO THERE
IS NO INCOME LIMITATION THERE'S
NO THERE'S NO IT THE YOU COULD
PUT YOU COULD PUT THE WHOLE AREA
UNDER ANY AYE HEFTY TECHNICALLY
I MEAN THERE THERE'S A REALLY US
BUT AS I SAID BEFORE POLITICAL
AGREEMENT.
THAT THE COURT SO THAT'S HE AYE
FD I THINK YOU COULD SEE IRVINE
COULD USE IT THEY'D OFFICE TO
OBVIOUSLY WOULD HAVE TO LOOK
THROUGH LOOK THREATEN AND MAKE
IT JUST MAKE DECISIONS BUT THEY
COULD USE IT.
UP THE CREEL LOG MAYBE NOT SO
MUCH BECAUSE OF THE INCOME
RESTRICTIONS BECAUSE THE CREEL
LAW WAS TRYING TO AT LEAST GET
BACK TO THE WHAT WAS THE COR
IDEA OF REDEVELOPMENT WHICH WAS.
YOU HAD A TRASHED AREA AND YOU
WANTED TO FIX IT UP YOU KNOW AND
AND AND TO THE EXTENT THE OLD
ALREADY A WAS. WAS A CRITICIZED
SOMETIMES.
THAT THEY WERE CRITICIZED
BECAUSE MAYBE THE AREA WASN'T.
WAS INVITED AND THAT NOT WAS
PART OF THE ISSUE SO YOU HAVE IF
YOU WANT TO DO REGULAR
INFRASTRUCTURE ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT YOU CAN GO TO ANY
AYE FD GO FOR IT. IF YOU'RE
TRYING TO DO URBAN DOWNTOWN
REDEVELOPMENT THEN SOMETHING
LIKE A CAREER OR MAYBE A WERE
WERE IMPROVED KOREA IS
SOMETHING.
THAT YOU COULD USE.
THAT'S THE THING ABOUT THE.
THE OUSING AUTHORITY IDEA
AGAIN THERE IS NO NO INCOME
LIMITATION IT'S KIND OF LIKE IN
THE YEAH E. FID. AND YOU HAVE A
LOT OF FLEXIBILITY AS TO WHERE
YOU CAN USE THAT IF YOU'RE GOING
TO GET SALES TAXES THOUGH YOU
NEED TO HAVE YOUR WHOLE
JURISDICTION IN ONE. BUT BUT YOU
YOU DON'T HAVE IT ISN'T IT THERE
ISN'T A RESTRICTION OF HOW MUCH
SALES TAXES YOU DONATE SO I
THINK THAT THAT AFFORDABLE
HOUSING.
AUTHORITY IS GOING TO BE A VERY
USEFUL TOOL.
ANOTHER THING THAT I WOULD LOOK
AT AND.
DAMN IT'S IT'S BEEN OVER A YEAR
SINCE WE DID OUR CREE ANALYSIS
BUT I BELIEVE WHEN WE DID OUR
CREATE ANALYSIS.
WELL LIBERTY STATION WHICH
HASN'T SEEN DIEGO IS A FORMER
NAVY BASE
AND I BELIEVE WE WERE ABLE TO
INCLUDE THAT INTO THAT ANALYSIS
AS AN ELIGIBLE CENSUS TRACT. BY
THE MERE FACT THAT IT WAS OF A
CLOSED MILITARY FACILITATORS
FACILITIES SO I BELIEVE THERE IS
A.
A CARVE OUT IN THE CREEL
LEGISLATION THAT ALLOWS FORMER
MILITARY BASES.
TO YOU THAT REGARDLESS OF WHAT
DEVELOPMENT YOU'VE ALREADY
STARTED.
JUNE TWO UNDERTAKEN HOW MUCH
BLOOD HAS BEEN ALLEVIATED IT'S
IT'S CONSIDER BLIGHTED.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ELESSAR ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS.
APPRECIATE YOUR BRIEFING AND
YOUR PERSPECTIVE VANDALIC FORTY
FUTURE CONVERSATIONS.
LET ME INVITE UP THE FINAL
PANEL TO PROVIDE OTHER
PERSPECTIVES ON TAX INCREMENT
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT TOOLS WE
HAVE FIGHT EGON TO PLAN. UP
FROM.
SPUR TRISH KELLY FROM VALLEY
VISION CRAG CASTELLANA OF FROM
THE PUBLIC INTEREST LAW PROJECT
AND DOROTHY JOHNSON FROM C.
SACK.
AND AS FOLKS GET SETTLED.
I WILL ASK
FOR PRESENTATIONS IN THE ORDER
IN THE HEARING AT WHICH WOULD
MEAN WE START WHISPER.
YOU TROUBLING.
I GOOD AFTERNOON A A HUNTER BUT
WAS SPUR WERE IN URBAN POLICY
THINK TANK AN ADVOCACY
ORGANIZATION BASED IN THE THREE
CENTRAL CITIES OF THE BAY AREA
WITH OFFICES IN SAN FRANCISCO.
OAKLAND AND SAN JOSE HAVE DONE A
LOT OF WORK ON URBAN
REDEVELOPMENT REVITALIZATION ON
PARTICULAR ENDURED ON STATION
SAN JOSE AND TRANSMIT TERMINAL
IN DOWNTOWN SAN FRANCISCO AND
I'VE. I'VE LET OUR WORK LOOKING
AT THE FUTURE OF THE THREE
DOWNTOWNS IN THE BAY AREA BUT
ACTUALLY IN PART TODAY WHAT I'M
HERE TO SHARE WITH YOU IS SOME
THOUGHTS AND WORK WE DID OVER
THE PAST YEAR AND A HALF. REALLY
LOOKING AT THE HIGH SPEED RAIL
SYSTEM AMONG THE OPPORTUNITY FOR
REVITALIZATION AROUND ON THE
RAIL STATIONS BOTH THE HIGH
SPEED RAIL I'M WILL BE MANAGING
BUT REALLY BROADLY THINKING
ABOUT RAIL IN THE OPPORTUNITY
AND SO I THINK THERE ARE COPIES.
OF THIS REPORT.
AROUND YOUR DESK AND AND I
RECOGNIZE YOU KNOW SOME VERY
IMPORTANT QUESTIONS ABOUT RURAL
AREAS THIS IMPORTANT QUESTIONS
ABOUT A VARIETY OF PLACES AND SO
WHAT I HOPE I CAN SPEAK TO IS A
LITTLE BIT OF SOME DISTINCTIONS.
BETWEEN SOME OF THE QUESTIONS WE
WERE LOOKING AT HERE FROM FROM
THE PRIOR OR ADDITIONS.
FROM SOME OF THE PRIOR PIECE
THEN REALLY ALSO I'M APPLYING
THIS THINKING ABOUT
REVITALIZATION.
IN A LITTLE AHEAD OF A BROADER
WAY ABOUT REALLY WHAT WE TRYING
TO ACCOMPLISH FOR THE BIG GOALS
OF OVER TRYING TO ACCOMPLISH AS
A STATE I'M AND IN PARTICULAR
PLACES. AND SO THE SO THE REPORT
THAT THAT WE DID WE WORK WITH
THE WITH A HIGH SPEED RAIL
AUTHORITY IN THE STRATEGIC
GROWTH COUNCIL AND A VARIETY OF
OTHER PEOPLE. I'M BUT IN PART
THE THE QUESTION THAT WE WERE
ASKING WAS WHAT IS THE ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT AND LAND USE
OPPORTUNITY FROM THIS MASSIVE
STATE INVESTMENT IT IS NOT JUST
A TRANSPORTATION PROJECT. IT IS
REALLY AN OPPORTUNITY TO RESHAPE
HOW THE STATE GROWS WHERE IT
GROWS AND TO BRING ECONOMIC
OPPORTUNITIES TO PARTS OF THE
STATE SO IN PART VII THE
EMPHASIS ON THE THINKING HERE
WERE. THE INTERMEDIATE STATIONS
AND PARTICULARLY IN THE SAN
JOAQUIN VALLEY AMID TO A CERTAIN
EXTENT GILROY IN AND AND SANTA
CLARA COUNTY THE PLACES WHERE
THE IMPACT OF RAIL INVESTMENT IS
NOT AS OBVIOUS
IF YOU LOOK AT JAPAN IF YOU LOOK
AT OTHER PARTS OF THE WORLD.
RAIL INVESTMENT ACTUALLY THE
BENEFITS CAN SOMETIMES A CREW
QUITE A BIT TO THATTODAY.
CENTRAL CITIES BUT WE WANTED TO
SAY IN CALIFORNIA WHAT'S GONNA
HAPPEN WEARING THE BENEFITS AND
BAKERSFIELD AND FRESNO AMBER
SAID AND SO IN A LOT OF THAT THE
WORK WE DID HERE WE HAD WE
CONVENED. A MEMBERS AND
REPRESENTATIVES FROM THE HIGH
SPEED RAIL STATION CITIES INTO A
SERIES OF DIALOGUES
THAT SAID I THINK A LOT OF THE
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT I SHARE
WITH YOU AT A HIGH LEVEL. ARE
VERY APPLICABLE TO SAN JOSE AND
APPLICABLE TO OAKLAND APPLICABLE
CERTAINLY TO SAN DIEGO AND LOS
ANGELES ON AND OTHER PARTS OF
THE STATE.
CITY BEGIN A COUPLE OF MAYBE
POINTS OF OF OF.
IN ADDITION BEYOND WHAT WE WE
HEARD FROM THE PEOPLE BEFORE I'M
ONE OF THEM IS REALLY THE IDEA
OF INSURING THAT THE STATE GETS
A RETURN ON THE INVESTMENT FOR A
LOT OF THE WORK THAT IT'S DOING
I THINK WE HEARD FROM THE LEAGUE
OF CITIES THE NOTION OF. IT
BEING APPROPRIATE FOR THERE TO
BE SOME LEVEL OF STATE OVERSIGHT
TO MEET STATE GOALS BUT TO KIND
OF TAKE THAT A STEP FURTHER WHEN
THE STATE IS MAKING AN
INVESTMENT HOW DOES THE STATE
ALSO PARTICIPATE. I'M IN SOME OF
THE UPSIDE.
A SECOND POINT IS REALLY
THINKING AROUND THE IDEA OF
JOINT GOVERNANCE OF KIND OF
LOCALS AND THE STATE
COLLECTIVELY WORKING TOGETHER TO
IMAGINE THE OUTCOMES OF THESE
PLACES SOMETHING WE DIDN'T DO IN
REDEVELOPMENT REDEVELOPMENTS
VERY MUCH. ON THE LOCAL PROGRAM
THERE'S A QUITE A VARIETY OF
DISTINCTION.
I'M A THIRD POINT THIS WAS
REFERENCE A LITTLE BIT FROM THE
FROM THE OTHERS SPEAKERS WAS
THAT THE TOOLS WE HAVE HAVE
LIMITATIONS BUT IN MANY WAYS ARE
NOT MANDATORY SAYS WE THINK
ABOUT ADDITIONAL TOOLS. TO WHAT
EXTENT DO WE WANT THE
PARTICIPATION IN THEM.
TO TO BE MANDATORY.
AND THEN I WOULD ALSO KIND OF
ADD ADD TO THAT TWO ADDITIONAL
POINTS ONE IS THAT WE'RE
PARTICULARLY INTERESTED IN THIS
CONVERSATION ABOUT COMMUNITY.
REDEVELOPMENT REVITALIZATION AS
BEING A LOT BROADER THAN
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT TOOLS IN
FACT THIS IS AN OPPORTUNITY TO
THINK ABOUT WHAT WE WANT TO
ACCOMPLISH THE STATE WATER SOME
OF OUR LARGER POLICY GOALS. AND
WHAT ARE SOME LARGER APPROACHES
TO THINK ABOUT THAT QUESTIONS
AROUND I'M REGIONAL LAND USE
AND IN A SENSE CAPTURING GROWTH
WITH IN URBAN AREAS WRIT LARGE
PRESERVING FARMLAND AND
PROTECTING. I'M OPEN SPACES IS
RELATED TO WHAT HAPPENS IN THE
COURSE OF THE CITY'S
I'M WHAT ARE THE CRITERIA WHAT
KIND OF PLANNING CRITERIA SHOULD
WE BE APPLYING TO PARTICULAR
COMMUNITIES SHOULD THE STATE BE
SETTING THOSE CRITERIA. ARE I'M.
IN ADDITION KIND OF TWO LAST
POINTS AROUND THE SORT OF AN
ADDITIONAL PIECE IS.
BE IMPLEMENTATION IS OFTEN
FORGOTTEN WE HEARD ABOUT
REDEVELOPMENT AGENCIES IS HUGE
LOSS OF HUMAN CAPITAL WITH WITH
THE END OF THOSE SYSTEMS WE ALSO
THE NEED TO THINK ABOUT THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE PLANS.
THE PROGRAMS IN CREATING SOME
KIND OF IN.
DEVELOPMENT CORPORATION OR SOME
SORT OF ENTITY THE AND THEY CAN
CARRY IT OUT AND I WOULD ALSO BE
REMISS BY NOT BRINGING UP THE
ROLE OF TRANSPORTATION AND THE
INTEGRATION OF ALL THE VARIOUS
INVESTMENTS. IN TRANSPORTATION
IN OUR DOWNTOWNS I MEAN OUR
STATION AREAS AND SO THE
PROSPECTIVE I'M BRINGING A
LITTLE BIT AND HERE IS HOW DO
WE.
ENSURE THAT THIS CONVERSATION
REALLY WORKS.
FOR RAIL STATIONS REALLY WORKS
FOR TRANSIT FACILITIES.
SO LET ME JUST MAKE A FEW POINTS
KIND OF ABOUT THE RAIL
OPPORTUNITY.
AND AND KIND OF SOME VERY
SPECIFIC A TARGETED
RECOMMENDATIONS ON WHAT TO DO
SO.
WE ARE WE ARE MAKING A MAJOR
INVESTMENT RAILING CALIFORNIA
HIGH SPEED RAIL IS A PIECE ABOUT
THE STATE RAIL PLAN IS ANOTHER
ONE AND SO WE HAVE DOZENS OF
PLACES IN CALIFORNIA THAT ARE
GONNA BE CONNECTED TO EACH
OTHER.
AS PART OF A NETWORK AND SO
THAT'S AN OPPORTUNITY HELP
REALIZE THE STATE'S CLIMATE
GOALS UNHOOK SHIFT PEOPLE AWAY
FROM FROM AUTOMOBILES AND IT'S
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT WE THINK A
LOT ABOUT AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND
HOUSING AROUND THIS PLACES. IT
IS ALSO VERY IMPORTANT WE THINK
ABOUT COMMERCIAL OF ELEMENT AND
JOBS AND DESTINATIONS AROUND
RAIL AND ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
WE'VE SEEN I'M INTERNATIONALLY
AND SEEN IN THE BAY AREA THAT.
IF RICHEST IN GETTING PEOPLE OUT
OF THEIR CARS GETTING PEOPLE ON
TO TRANSIT ON TO RAIL WE GOT A
BUNCH OF JOBS AND DESTINATIONS
AROUND THE RAIL STATIONS.
AND THAT'S SOMETHING THAT IN
THESE CONVERSATIONS ABOUT TOOLS
AND IN THESE CONVERSATIONS ABOUT
TRANSIT ON THAT SIDE OF LAND
USE.
SHOULDN'T CERTAINLY NEEDS TO BE
A PART OF THAT.
AND THEN I AS I MENTIONED BEFORE
WE'VE ALSO TALKED ABOUT THE
IMPORTANCE OF MAKING SURE THAT
THE STATE GETS A RETURN ON ITS
INVESTMENT.
BUT WE'VE HEARD A LOT ABOUT
THESE CHALLENGES.
AND IN PARTICULAR THE THE THE
AREA THAT I WANT TO BE OUT A
LITTLE BIT TOO IS THINKING ABOUT
THE CHALLENGES OF OF PLACES
WHERE THE MARKET. CONTEXT IS IS
REALLY DIFFICULT CERTAINLY.
THE PARTS OF SAN DIEGO WE'RE
HEARING ABOUT THERE'S A NEED FOR
PUBLIC INVESTMENT TO KIND OF GET
THE PRIVATE MARKET TO COME IN
LATER THAT'S ONE SET OF MARKET
CHALLENGES THERE'S ANOTHER SET
OF MARKET CHALLENGES WE TAKE A
PLACE LIKE A DOWNTOWN FRESNO.
WHERE WE HAVE SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT
OF INVESTMENT THERE'S GOING TO
BE PLANNED FOR HIGH SPEED RAIL
STATION THERE'S AN EXISTING
AMTRAK STATION A BUT UNDER
CURRENT MARKET CONDITIONS? A AN
OFFICE BUILDING THAT SAY COULD
GENERATE ABOUT A HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY BUCKS.
IN SCHOOL A KIND OF SQUARE FOOT
OF HUNDRED EIGHTY DOLLARS OUT OF
A THREE HUNDRED FIFTY DOLLARS
SQUARE FOOT COST
TO BUILD A NEW OFFICE BUILDING
SOLELY ABOUT HALF. OF THE VALUE
OF THAT BUILDING CAN BE
GENERATED BY THE CURRENT MARKET
RENT SO YOU HAVE A GAP.
I'M A MAJOR GAP AND THAT'S IN
FACT WHY YOU DON'T SEE MARKET
RATE DEVELOPMENT I'M IN THAT
CONTEXT.
EVEN A PLACE LIKE DOWNTOWN
OAKLAND ON WHICH FOR FOR DECADES
HAS HAD BART HAS STRUGGLED TO
GET MARKET RATE DEVELOPMENT OVER
A HUGE AMOUNT OF THIS TIME
PERIOD SO WE KNOW THAT. RAIL ON
ITS OWN AND SOME OF THESE
EXISTING TOOLS WE HAD ON ITS OWN
WERE INSUFFICIENT SO WE HAVE TO
THINK A LITTLE BIT MORE BROADLY
ARM AND IT TO ENSURE THAT THAT
TAKES PLACE.
ANOTHER CHALLENGE WE'VE ALSO
SEEN IS THAT SOME TO THAT THERE
ARE TIMES THAT THE VISION THAT A
LOCAL GOVERNMENT HAS FOR WHAT
SHOULD HAPPEN IN THEIR RAIL
STATION OR IN THEIR DOWNTOWN.
MIGHT NOT REINFORCE OVERALL
STATEWIDE GOALS AND THERE MIGHT
BE THE DESIRE FOR I'M ONE STORY
TOWN HOMES AS IMPORTANT AS THOSE
ARE. ACROSS THE STREET FROM A
HIGH SPEED RAIL STATION ORB
SURFACE PARKING LOTS ARE
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF PARKING OR
OTHER KIND OF VISIONS THAT THAT
ULTIMATELY AT THE END OF THE
DAY.
ARE PROBABLY NOT IN THE BEST
INTEREST OF THE STATE IF WE LOOK
FORWARD SEVERAL DECADES
SO HOW DO WE ENSURE THAT THE
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ARE SORT OF
RISING TO THE CHALLENGE. OF THE
OPPORTUNITY AND THAT THE STATE
IS REALLY ENSURE THAT IT GETS A
RETURN ON THE INVESTMENT ON THAT
THAT IT'S PUTTING INTO THESE
CONCEPTS.
AND OF COURSE WE WE ALSO KNOW
THAT THE TOOLS THEMSELVES AS
WE'VE BEEN SPENDING THE
AFTERNOON THINKING ABOUT ARE
INSUFFICIENT TO THE TASK AND I
THINK TO CUT TO THE CHASE ON
THAT THEY'RE JUST SIMPLY NOT
ENOUGH MONEY. WHEN YOU TAKE THE
PORTION OF THE THE VOLUNTARY
CONTRIBUTION YOU KNOW THE CITY
COULD DO IT BUT THEN THE COUNTY
MAY NOT PARTICIPATE.
.
AND AND AND I WOULD ARGUE ONE
ADDITIONAL PIECE THAT THAT A LOT
OF WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT IS
SIMPLY THE LOCAL PORTION.
OR THE VARIOUS PARTS A LOCAL
GOVERNMENT.
STATE COULD BE A PARTICIPANT I
THINK THE NIFTY I'M CONCEPT FROM
LAST YEAR IS A VERSION OF THE
LOCAL PORTION OF THE SALES TAX
BUT MAYBE WE COULD TAKE IT A
STEP FURTHER AND IMAGINE SOME
OTHER STATE INVESTMENTS.
SO LET ME CLOSE WITH A COUPLE OF
KIND OF RECOMMENDATIONS FROM
FROM WHAT WE SEE ARE COMING OUT
HERE IN THIS I WOULD SAY THESE
REALLY BUILD FROM WHAT WE WHAT
WE LEARN FROM FROM REDEVELOPMENT
BUT REALLY YOU'RE TRYING TO TAKE
IT. ON TO THE NEXT LEVEL.
FIRST POINT AND AND ALL I WANNA
GET TO THE TOOL SPECIFICALLY BUT
I WANNA MAKE KIND OF THIS OF THE
BROADER PIECES IS THAT THE LOCAL
PLANS FOR THESE DISTRICTS FOR
THESE AREAS WHAT HOWEVER THERE
TO FIND I'M I'M PARTICULARLY
FOCUSED YOU'RE ON SORT OF RAIL
STATION AREAS. BUT WE CAN HAVE
DISTRICTS OF ANY KIND THROUGHOUT
THE STATE. THEY OUGHT TO BE
DEVELOPED IN LINE WITH SOME KIND
OF STATE OVERSIGHT GOALS OR IS
IT SOME SORT OF VISION OF WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO GET TO WHETHER
THAT'S REDUCING OUR IMPACT ON
CLIMATE CHANGE OR PRESERVING
FARMLAND. ENSURING TRANSIT
RIDERSHIP THESE ARE IMPORTANT
STATEWIDE GOALS SO WHAT'S BEING
PRODUCED LOCALLY SHOULD SHOULD
REINFORCE THAT.
THE SECOND IS THAT WE NEED SOME
KIND OF A DELIVERY ENTITY
WHETHER IT'S A DEVELOPMENT
CORPORATION THAT YES MIGHT HAVE
THESE POWERS OF EMINENT DOMAIN
BUT IT MIGHT ALSO HAVE BONDING
AUTHORITY MIGHT ALSO BE HAVE THE
EXPERTISE. OF PEOPLE WHO CAN
REALLY MAKE A DEAL HAPPEN I'M
BECAUSE WE CAN HAVE WHATEVER
TOOLS WE WANT BUT YOU NEED YOU
NEED YOU KNOW THE EXPERTISE BUT
ALSO THAT KIND OF. POWERFUL
ENTITY THAT CAN REALLY AREN'T
MAKE IT HAPPEN AND THEN OF
COURSE WE NEED TO REALLY THINK
ABOUT ABOUT MODIFICATIONS TO THE
TOOLS SO.
.
FIVE VERY BRIEF MODIFICATIONS
ONE.
THE SHARING IS NOT VOLUNTARY
THAT THERE'S SOME KIND OF
MANDATORY.
PARTICIPATION SOAP CITIES AND
COUNTIES TOGETHER ARE BOTH
PUTTING IN THEIR PROPERTY TAX
INCREMENT IS AN EXAMPLE.
AND IF THEIR THEIR DISTRICT.
SECOND KIND OF UP MODIFICATION.
AND AND WHEN I SAY MODIFICATION
THESE COULD BE LEGISLATIVE
MODIFICATIONS TO THE E. AYE
FDA'S COULD BE A NEW PIECE OF
LEGISLATION MY UNDERSTANDING IS
THE REDEVELOPMENT LAW IS STILL
ON THE BOOKS.
SOME THAT STUFF COULD COME BACK
BUT JUST IN TERMS OF PARTICULAR
CHANGES I'M POINT TO. THAT THERE
IS BOTH STATE AND LOCAL
PARTICIPATION THAT IF THE LOCALS
ARE PUTTING UP THE INCREMENTAL
PROPERTY TAX. MAYBE THE STATE'S
ALSO PUTTING UP ITS INCREMENT IN
THE SALES TAX
NOT THE LOCAL PORTION BUT THAT
BUT THE PORTION GOES TO THE
STATE GENERAL FUND.
AND MAYBE THEN THE LOCALS ARE
ALSO PUTTING UP THE GROWTH IN
THE TRANSIT OCCUPANCY TAX
IT'S THAT YOU KNOW THE HOTEL TAX
OR OTHER TOOLS SO WE CREATE A
VEHICLE. OR MULTIPLE REVENUE
STREAMS CAN COME IN AND IT GETS
BETTER.
POINT THREE THAT THE STATE IS
INVOLVED IN SOME KIND OF
OVERSIGHT.
NOT JUST SETTING SOME CRITERIA
BY WHICH A LOCAL DISTRICT PLAN
PASSED TO IT HERE BUT MAYBE
THERE'S A SEAT ON THE LOCAL
BOARD FOR.
SOME MEMBER OF THE STATE FROM
THE STRATEGIC GROWTH COUNCIL OP
ARE AND THEIR THERE'S A SHARED
GOVERNANCE IDEA LOCAL COUNTY
MAYBE THE MPO MAYBE THE TRANSIT
OPERATORS APPROPRIATE. THAT
THERE'S SHARED GOVERNANCE AND
MULTIPLE PIECES.
AND THEN POINTS FOR AND FIVE A
MUCH SMALLER ONE IS THAT IN SOME
PARTS OF THE STATE AND WE REALLY
NEED SOME EARLY STAGE FINANCING
TO GET PROJECTS OFF THE GROUND
TO KICKSTART TAX INCREMENT
FINANCING.
SO THAT THAT THE PLACES THAT ARE
GOING TO BE GENERATING AS MUCH
LOCALLY WE NEED WE NEED TO KIND
OF JUMP START THEM AND MAYBE
SOME OF THOSE STATE REVENUES ARE
APPROPRIATE.
AND THEN AND THEN FINALLY A
SMALLER ONE THIS EXISTS IN SOME
OF THE BILLS BUT WE HAVE TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE THE BONDS THAT CAN
BE APPROVED WITH WITHOUT A
PUBLIC VOTE. I'M KIND OF MAKE
SURE THAT THIS PROCESS GOES
FORWARD.
BUT SO LONG AS WHAT'S BEING
PLANTED ENVISIONED IS MATCHING
UP WITH.
THOSE STATEWIDE GOALS FROM THE
OUTSET AND IS A HEARING WITH THE
PLAN THAT WAS REALLY DEVELOPED
AND IT'S GOT A BROAD VISION OF
OF WHAT TO HAPPEN IN THOSE
PLACES.
SO IN CONCLUSION WHAT WHAT WE'RE
ARGUING WHAT WE SEEING IS IT
THERE ARE A SET OF IDEAS THAT WE
SAW AS WE WERE THINKING ABOUT
THIS QUESTION FROM THE
STANDPOINT OF WHAT SHOULD WE DO
ABOUT HIGH SPEED RAIL STATIONS.
BUT WE CAN BROADEN FROM THAT AND
EXTRAPOLATE FROM THAT THAT THIS
IS PERFECTLY APPROPRIATE AS WELL
FOR MANY RAIL STATIONS IN
CALIFORNIA.
AND INDEED SOME OF THESE IDEAS
GENERALLY APPLIED.
THEY NEED TO BE TARGETED AND
KIND OF TWEAK TO DIFFERENT KINDS
OF CONTACTS BUT SOME OF THE
POLICY PRINCIPLES OF STATE AND
LOCAL SHARING AND PARTICIPATION
IN MEETING THESE SORT OF GOALS I
THINK APPLIED. DIFFERENTLY TO
RURAL AREAS AMONG OTHER PARTS
THE STATE TO HABITAT QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
BUT A QUESTIONS COLLEAGUES.
JUST HAD CUT.
TWO TWO QUICK QUESTIONS I THANK
YOU FOR THIS REPORT I HAVEN'T
HAD A CHANCE TO I GO THROUGH IT
THOROUGHLY. BUT IF IT'S POSSIBLE
MAYBE AFTER THIS IF YOU COULD
JUST SEND A QUICK EMAIL TO
HIGHLIGHT WHICH ASPECTS OF IT
YOU THINK WE COULD AS
LEGISLATORS SORT OF LEAN INTO I
THINK ABOUT. HOW THE STREET SIDE
I TOOK NOTES ON THE FIVE BUT I
COULDN'T FIND THEM IN YOUR? IN
YOUR PRESENTATION AYE YET I ONE
ONE THING THERE THERE'S A
THERE'S A DOCUMENT ON THE BACK
THAT I HAVE COPIES OF I CAN
SHARE TO EACH OF YOU BUT IT'S A
PLAN OF ACTION THAT ACTUALLY HAS
A SERIES OF BULLETS. UNDER THE
STATE LEGISLATURE.
HOW CORRECT THE SOME OF THE
PARTICULAR RECOMMENDATIONS AND
I'D SAY IT'S REALLY AROUND THE
THE KIND OF?
ESTABLISHING SOME OF THE READ
THE REVITALIZATION TOOL.
IS PERFECTLY WITHIN YOUR.
MANDATE AND I THINK THAT'S VERY
MUCH THE DISCUSSION OF X. HERE.
AND I MEAN I COULD VERY QUICKLY
SAY IT'S IT'S REALLY
RECOMMENDATIONS.
TO.
SIX SEVEN.
NINE ELEVEN TWO SIX
SEVEN. NINE ELEVEN OKAY BUT
TODAY WE'VE REALLY BEEN FOCUSING
MORE ON RECOMMENDATION SIX WHICH
IS THIS REVITALIZATION TOOL. AND
TWEAKS TO THAT GREAT THANK YOU
FOR FOCUSING US AND THEN A
SECOND QUESTION
HOW'S THE SPEND DISCUSSED WITH
THE HIGH SPEED AUTHORITY. WHAT
CONVERSATIONS HAVE HAPPENED AT
THE STATE LEVEL WITH THE VARIOUS
TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITIES SAID
EVEN WORKING WITH?
GREAT NIGHT SIX SO I I'D I'D
NEGLECTED TO SAY THAT MY
BEGINNING SO THIS WAS DEVELOPED
WITH WITH HIGH SPEED RAIL
AUTHORITY AND WAS TAKEN THROUGH
THAT THERE'S A TRANSIT LAND USE
COMMITTEE OF THE HIGH SPEED RAIL
AUTHORITY. AND SO THIS CAME OUT
OF A SERIES OF CONVERSATIONS ON
THAT WE HAD THERE AND SO SINCE
THEN THERE'S BEEN IT THERE'S
BEEN A SERIES OF FOLLOW ON
QUESTIONS. OF OF AND
CONVERSATIONS ON HOW HOW DO WE
GET SOME OF THESE IDEAS
IMPLEMENTED I THINK IS QUITE A
BIT OF INTEREST.
I'M IN YOU KNOW A CALLOUSED ON
HIGH SPEED RAIL AND AND OTHER
PARTS OF THE ADMINISTRATION IN
IMAGINING HOW DO WE IMPLEMENT
SOME OF THESE IDEAS TO REALLY
ENSURE THAT WE GET THE RIGHT OUT
COMES AROUND. I THINK PARTICULAR
AROUND RAIL STATIONS BROADER
THAN THAN SIMPLY HIGH SPEED RAIL
THAT REALLY INTERCITY RAIL
ACROSS CALIFORNIA THANK I THINK
I MAY REQUEST A MEETING WITH YOU
AND OTHER COLLEAGUES FROM THAT
CONVERSATION PROBLY OFFLINE TO
UNDERSTAND. THAT WHAT THE
INTEREST ISN'T SPECIFICALLY
WHERE WE MIGHT BE ABLE TO GO
THIS YEAR ON SOME.
WE'RE HAPPY TO DO SO GREAT ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS. MISS WALDRON.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
.
NOT VERY INTERESTING YOU KNOW
STUDY I I COULDN'T GET THROUGH
ALL OF IT BECAUSE WE JUST GOT IT
YESTERDAY AFTERNOON BUT.
.
I HAD.
SERVED IT ON THE CITY COUNCIL
IN ESCONDIDO WHICH IS ONE OF THE
STATIONS.
.
AND I ALSO SERVED FOR EIGHT
YEARS ON THE LOCAL.
TRANSIT AUTHORITY.
SO. WE HAVE DURING MY TENURE WE
HAD GOTTEN THE FULL FUNDING
GRANT AGREEMENT FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT TO ACTUALLY IMPLEMENT
THE COMMUTER RAIL IT GOES FROM.
THE COAST INLAND. THE SPRINTER
RAIL LINE.
AND WHAT WE DID ON ALL THE
STATIONS WAS A SIMILAR PLANNING
CONCEPT YOU KNOW. REALLY WORKING
WITH EACH CITY BECAUSE.
WHEN IS THE TRANSIT AUTHORITY ON
THE RAIL LINE SO WE HAD
AUTHORITY. ON THAT RAIL LINE
ALONG WITH. THEM BE IN SF.
OF FREE WHICH WE SHARED.
.
SO FOR THE PLANNING WE WORKED
WITH EACH CITY INDIVIDUALLY AND
WE WERE ABLE TO YOU KNOW DO A
LOT OF THESE GOALS AS FAR AS THE
PLANNING.
BUT THE DISTRICT ITSELF.
CONTROLLED WHAT IT DID ON THE
LAND THAT OWNED IT HAD ACTUALLY
BOUGHT UP LAND AROUND SO WAS
ABLE TO DO YOU KNOW SOME
DEVELOPMENTS A MIXED USE AND
THINGS LIKE THAT HOME. BECAUSE
YOU WANNA. TAKE FULL ADVANTAGE
OF THE STATIONS.
IN KNOW FOR PEOPLE GETTING THE
WORK STUDENTS WE EVEN A. CREATED
A SEPARATE. BYPASS OF THE LINE
TO GO TO.
.
CAL STATE SAN MARCUS.
WHICH THE STUDENTS USE.
.
AND I'M JUST WONDERING I GUESS
ONE OF THE THINGS ONE YOU KNOW.
I HEADS OF JUGGLE BETWEEN BEING
A CITY COUNCIL MEMBER AND WORK
ON THE TRANSIT BOARD. WAS THE
CONCEPT OF THE LOCAL CONTROL
WHICH.
YOU KNOW IF THE STATE.
HAS OVERSIGHT JUST LIKE WE AT
THE TRANSIT DISTRICT HAD
OVERSIGHT OVER WHAT WE OWNED
BUT WE WERE NOT ABLE TO. DICTATE
TO THE CITIES YOU KNOW WHAT THEY
COULD DO WE COULD WORK WITH THEM
AND I'M WONDERING. YOU KNOW
WITHOUT BYPASS AND LOCAL CONTROL
WHICH CITIES WANNA KEEP HOW CAN.
YOU KNOW THE CONCEPTS THE STATE
OPERATE LIKE A CARROT ON THE
STICK KIND OF OMAR AND INCENTIVE
TO BRING THE CITY'S.
YOU KNOW THERE'S SHOULD BE AN
INCENTIVE FOR THEM. I MEAN THEY
CAN SEE THE GOALS OF THE OF THE
TAX INCREMENTS AND THINGS LIKE
THAT.
AND THEY UNFORTUNATE THING WAS
THE AREA WHERE ARE TRANSIT
STATION IS WAS IN THE CENTER OF
OUR REDEVELOPMENT AREA WHICH WAS
JUST. YOU KNOW BEGGING TO BE
WE'VE DEVELOPED SO WHEN WE LOST
THAT IT REALLY KILLED US SO I
JUST I JUST WANNA MAKE SURE
WE'RE NOT GONNA.
OVERRIDING LOCAL CONTROL ALSO I
THINK YOU'RE YOU'RE RAISING A
REALLY GOOD POINT BUT IT BUT ON
A IF WHAT I HEAR FROM YOUR
EXAMPLE IS SOMETHING WE SEE
ACROSS CALIFORNIA. THERE'S A
CHALLENGE OF FRAGMENTED DECISION
MAKING THAT LOCAL CONTROL OFTEN
REFERS SIMPLY TO THE KIND OF
LAND USE DECISIONS AT THE LOCAL
CITY OR COUNTY HAS. BUT THEY'RE
ALSO A SERIES OF OTHER DECISIONS
ABOUT WHERE'S THE TRANSIT SYSTEM
GONNA PUT ITS TRAIN AND WHO HAS
AUTHORITY ON THE TRACKS AND
THERE'S SEVENTY FIVE OTHER
DECISIONS ARE OFTEN MADE BY OF
KIND OF IN A FRAGMENTED
GOVERNANCE STRUCTURE. AND WHAT I
THINK PART OF WHAT WHAT WE'VE
LEARNED AND WE ACTUALLY BROUGHT
UP A GROUP OF LEADERS FROM SAN
JOSE LAST SUMMER TO LOOK AT RAIL
STATIONS IN. AND FRANCE AND AND
THE NETHERLANDS TO UNDERSTAND
THIS PARTICULAR QUESTION YOU'RE
GETTING OUT AND WE HEARD A VERY
GOOD POINT FROM ONE OF THE
PEOPLE WHO DONE STATION ABOUT
MEN IN THE NETHERLANDS WHICH
WAS.
ALL THESE ENTITIES INVOLVED THE
RAIL SYSTEM TO LOCAL CITIES THE
NATIONAL GOVERNMENT THE REGIONAL
GOVERNMENT.
THEY ALL PARTICIPATED TOGETHER
IN FORMING A JOINT GOVERNING
BOARD TO DEVELOP THE STATIONS.
THEY ALL GOT
LESS THAN THEY WANTED.
BUT MORE THAN THEY EXPECTED.
SO BY JOINTLY GOING IN AND
SAYING WE ARE GONNA MAKE
SOMETHING BIG HAPPEN IN THIS
PLACE YET MAYBE GOT TO GIVE UP A
LITTLE BIT IF WE WORKED
INDEPENDENTLY.
BUT WE ACHIEVE SOMETHING MUCH
BIGGER BY COMING TOGETHER
AROUND.
AND SO THIS IS A LITTLE BROADER
THAN THE REVITALIZATION
CONVERSATION THIS AFTERNOON BUT
THERE'S AN OPPORTUNITY TO DO
SHARED GOVERNANCE AROUND
STATIONS WHERE YOU'VE GOT UP A
BUNCH OF PEOPLE. PUTTING MONEY
AND THAT MIGHT LEAD TO WEAR HIM
OF THE TRACKS HOW DO YOU GET THE
TRAINS TO CONNECT WITH EACH
OTHER WHO BUILDS RUNS A STATION.
WHO BUILDS THE BUILDINGS ON IT
WHAT REVITALIZATION TOOLS HELP
THE NEW HOUSING AND COMMERCIAL
DEVELOPMENT HAPPENING ALL OF
THOSE PIECES TOGETHER SO I THINK
IT CAN BE DONE? ABSOLUTELY
WITHOUT UNDERMINING LOCAL
CONTROL BUT ACTUALLY HELPING
REALIZE THE VISION THAT THE
LOCAL CITIES HAVE BY GIVING THEM
ACCESS TO RESOURCES AND OTHER
OPPORTUNITIES THEY'RE WORKING IN
A MORE COORDINATED WAY. WITH
TRANSIT WITH THE STATE WITH
THESE OTHER ENTITIES.
BOB WOODWORKING NO IN LA
WOULDN'T WORK IN ESCONDIDO OR
WINTERS ARE YOU KNOW RIGHT SO
AND NEEDS COMMUNITY HAS ITS OWN.
YOU KNOW ULTIMATE VISION.
RIGHT SO I IT'S KIND OF LIKE A
JOINT POWERS AUTHORITIES TYPE OF
THING.
THAT CAN DO FINANCING YEAH I CAN
DO FINANCING BUT I ALSO THINK
IT'S IT'S ALSO IT'S THE
COORDINATION OF. WHERE'S THAT
BUS STOP IS THE BUS STOP GOING
TO BE ON WHAT SIDE OF THE
BUILDING IT'S NOT IT'S NOT JUST
THE FINANCING IT'S ALSO SOME OF
THE. THE TRANSPORTATION
DECISIONS IN THE LOCATION OF
PARKING AND I THINK TO MAKE
THESE DISTRICTS WORK HAVING. ALL
THOSE ENTITIES AT THE TABLE IN A
COORDINATED WAY CAN HELP MAKE
THIS HAPPEN.
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR PRESENTATION MOVE ON TO.
FISH KELLY SHE IS THE MANAGING.
DIRECTOR AT VALLEY VISION
WELCOME.
VERY MUCH.
CHILDREN. I AM VERY HAPPY TO BE
HERE TODAY VALLEY VISION IS OF
REGIONAL CIVIC LEADERSHIP
ORGANIZATION WERE BASED HERE IN
SACRAMENTO AND IN. STOCKTON AND
WE ALSO COLLABORATE WITH MANY
PARTNERS ACROSS
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA WERE PART OF
A STATEWIDE NETWORK OF REGIONAL
COLLABORATIONS CALLED.
CALIFORNIA STORAGE OF NETWORK.
SO MY OWN BACKGROUND IS THAT
I'VE SPENT A LOT OF TIME
CONSULTING AS AN ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT PRACTITIONER WITH
CITIES AND COUNTIES I'VE DONE A
LOT OF RURAL ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT STRATEGIES I
PREPARED GRANT APPLICATIONS FOR
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS SO. I'VE
SEEN FIRST HAND THAT THAT
CAPACITY ISSUE A LOT OF TIMES
CONSULTANTS ARE HIRED ESPECIALLY
IN RURAL AREAS BECAUSE THEY DO
NOT. HAVE THE CAPACITY TO
PREPARE. AND COMPETE FOR FUNDING
FOR WHICH THEY ARE ELIGIBLE.
TELEVISION ALSO MANAGES THE
REGIONAL BROADBAND CONSORTIUM
WHICH IS FUNDED BY THE PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION. AND THAT
IS TO TRY TO PROVIDE OUT FUNDING
FOR EIGHTEEN CONSORTIUM ACROSS
THE STATE. SIMILAR TO OURS TO
TRY TO ADDRESS OUR BROADBAND
GAPS AND SO. WE HAVE LOOKED AT
THINGS LIKE YAHYA YAHYA PHDS.
AND WE HAVE NOT HAD A LOT OF
UPTAKE FOR SOME OF THE REASONS
YOU'VE HEARD IN WHICH WE'D LIKE
TO.
DISCUSS TODAY.
WE ALSO HAVE A FEDERAL GRANT TO
PROMOTE FOOD BEVERAGE
MANUFACTURING IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY WITH OTHER PARTNERS AND
THAT INCLUDES INFRASTRUCTURE.
NEEDS AND CHALLENGES AND SO
AGAIN WE FACE A LOT OF THESE
ISSUES AROUND WIDE THESE TOOLS
HAVE BEEN ABLE TO. TO BE UP TO
SPEED YET.
SO ONE THING I'D LIKE TO
REFERENCE IS THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION FOR LOCAL ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT PREPARED A PRIMER ON
THESE NEW FINANCING TOOLS WHICH
I THINK IS VERY VALUABLE. WILL
PROVIDE THAT AND SOME OF MY
REMARKS TODAY ARE FROM.
FROM THIS PRIMER AND THEY DID A
VERY GOOD FACT SHEET AS WELL.
SO. THEIR BIGGEST OUR FOCUS IS
THAT THESE TOOLS ARE GOING TO BE
VERY USEFUL AND WE NEED TO PUT
THEM IN PLACE NOW TO PREPARE FOR
THE FUTURE BUT THERE ARE A LOT
OF CHALLENGES. FOR BOTH THE
PLANNING IN THE IMPLEMENTATION
AS WAS MENTIONED AND SO ONE OF
THE CHALLENGES ARE ARE THAT
THEY'RE EXPENSIVE TO SET UP SO
INCLUDE STAFF TIME CONSULTANTS
SPECIAL COUNSEL. AND YOU NEED TO
CONSIDER THE TIME IN THE COSTS
FOR THINGS LIKE YOU HAVE TO DO
REVENUE ESTIMATES TO DETERMINE
FISCAL FEASIBILITY. UNIT OUT%
REACHING NEGOTIATIONS WITH
FINANCING AUTHORITIES FORMATION
OF A PUBLIC FINANCE AGENCY OR
JPA IF NECESSARY YOU HAVE TO
DRAFT A PLAN FOR ADOPTION. AND
BOTH OF THESE ARE SUBSTANTIVE
DOCUMENTS AND THEY'RE SUBJECT TO
SEEK WORK AND THEN IN THE CASE
OF A SEE OUR. OUR AYE A YOU MAY
NEED A BOAT
SO THERE ARE A LOT OF MECHANICS
TO PUTTING THESE TOOLS TOGETHER
THAT DO HAVE A COST IMPLICATION.
IN A CAPACITY IN STAFFING
IMPLICATION FOR COMMUNITIES.
ANOTHER ISSUE THAT WAS RAISED
WAS ABOUT THE FINANCING PIECE SO
IF YOU HAVE A SHOVEL READY
PROJECT IN YOU READY TO GET INTO
THE GROUND BUT YOU HAVE A BILL
YOU TAX INCREMENT FINANCING UP.
HOW DO YOU GET THAT PROJECT
GOING SO THIS IS WHERE THE IDEA
PUBLIC PRIVATE PARTNERSHIPS IN
WORKING WITH OTHER INVESTORS TO
COMMIT ON THE FRONT END? IS
GOING TO BE WHAT YOU NEED TO GET
THE PROJECT GOING AS YOU BUILD
THE INCREMENT. BUT WITH THE
IMPROVEMENT ONE OF THE FINANCING
TOOLS CAN BE THE BONDS BUT IF
YOU HAVE TO GO FOR VOTER
APPROVAL FOR FIFTY FIVE PERCENT
AND YOU DON'T GET THE BOND
APPROVAL THEN YOU LOSE THE
FUNDING ALSO. SO YOU KNOW YOU
SORT OF YOU DON'T HAVE AN
ALIGNMENT OF YOUR FUNDING
SOURCES SO.
WHAT THE OF PRIMER BASICALLY
SAID IN CONSULTATION WITH A LOT
OF PRACTITIONERS IS THAT THESE
TOOLS HAVE THE GREATEST
POTENTIAL FOR SUCCESS? WHEN
THERE ARE MULTIPLE LAYERS OF
FINANCING AUTHORITIES
COLLABORATING TOGETHER WHO WHICH
OR HIGHLY MOTIVATED TO MOVE THE
PROJECTS TOGETHER FOR FORWARD
TOGETHER AND THEY HAVE STRONG
COMMUNITY SUPPORT. AND I THINK
THAT'S A LOT OF WHAT YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT IS THE
COLLABORATION BUT AGAIN IT TAKES
TIME TO PUT PARTNERSHIP
TOGETHER.
SO THAT'S JUST THAT'S JUST A
REALITY THAT WE NEED TO TAKE
INTO CONSIDERATION.
.
ANOTHER SUGGESTION WAS THAT YOU
NEED TO THINK OF THE I HAVE TO
USE AS BEST USED AS PART OF A
COMPREHENSIVE PLAN AND NOT AS A
ONE OFF.
FOR PROJECT LEVEL FINANCING
BECAUSE OF THESE REQUIREMENTS
FOR DIFFERENT KINDS OF. A
FUNDING STRUCTURES AND IT DOES
NOTE THAT THE ADMINISTRATION OF
ANY IFD CAN BE CUMBERSOME AND
COSTLY BECAUSE OF JUST
ADMINISTRATIVE TIME. PROJECT
OVERSIGHT PROJECT FINANCING IN
FUNDING TRACKING AND THE LOCAL
JURISDICTION IS RESPONSIBLE FOR
THE OUTCOMES. KNOW WE HAD TALKED
IN THIS REGION WITH THE RAIL
YARDS IT'S THE BIGGEST INFILL
PROJECT WEST OF THE MISSISSIPPI
AND THEY'RE TRYING TO DO ANY I
HAVE DE THEIR FOR INFRASTRUCTURE
INCLUDING BROADBAND. AND YOU
KNOW THEY'VE BEEN WORKING ON IT
FOR A COUPLE OF YEARS SO.
I THINK THERE'S POTENTIAL BUT WE
NEED TO BE REALISTIC ABOUT WHAT
IT TAKES TO PUT THESE PIECES
TOGETHER.
SO SOME OF OUR OBSERVATIONS ARE
THAT.
THE THE PROCESS CAN BE
COMPLICATED AND EXPENSIVE.
.
I THINK THAT THE ISSUE OF
CAPACITY IS REALLY IMPORTANT AND
AND THE IDEA THAT WOULD PROVIDE
SOME KIND OF CAPACITY TO
JURISDICTIONS AND PARTNERS TO
IMPLEMENT THESE TOOLS. WOULD BE
REALLY USEFUL IN THIS IS WHERE
PARTNERSHIP WITH.
THE JURISDICTIONS AND THE WEEK
GROUPS LIKE CAL LEAD WHICH HAVE
ACTUALLY HAVE A FINANCING
AUTHORITY TO COULD BE VERY
HELPFUL.
WE NEED TO CONSIDER MARKET
CONDITIONS AND ADDRESSING THE
CHALLENGE WHEN MARKETS DOWNTURN
AND HOW THAT AFFECTS THE TAX
INCREMENT REVENUES AND HOW THAT
MATCHES TO THE INFRASTRUCTURE
COSTS THAT YOU'RE TRYING TO PUT
IN PLACE.
AND WHAT WE NEED TO CONSIDER
HAVE CONSIDERATION FOR LONG TERM
FINANCING OUT FOR PROJECTS
BECAUSE THESE ARE ALL ON A LONG
TERM TIME CYCLE.
SO THE IDEA PARTNERSHIPS AND
INVESTORS IS REALLY IMPORTANT
FOR RURAL AREAS. THIS BURLY
AREAS HIGH CAPACITY CHALLENGES
BEFORE. REDEVELOPMENT EVER WENT
AWAY.
SO WE NEED TO CONSIDER TO THAT
RURAL AREAS IN MANY PARTS OF THE
STATE INCLUDING THIS REGION CAN
ALSO NOT USE MANY OF THE
FINANCING TOOLS THAT THAT ARE
AVAILABLE FROM THE FEDERAL
AGENCIES BECAUSE OF WORLD
DEFINITION ISSUES.
SO WHEN YOU LOOK AT ABOUT TRYING
TO LAYER MULTIPLE SOURCES OF
FUNDING THAT'S REALLY BEEN A
CONSTRAINT FOR US.
SOME OF THE FEDERAL FUNDING
PROGRAMS DO HAVE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE A CAPACITY BUILDING.
AND I THINK IF WE COULD LEVERAGE
SOME OF THOSE THAT WOULD BE
VALUABLE VOTE WE MIGHT LOOK AT
REPLICATING SOME OF THOSE TOOLS
ON OUR OWN. OF FINANCING
PROGRAMS HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
I THINK WE ALSO NEED TO
UNDERSTAND THAT IN RURAL AREAS
WE CANNOT BUILD HOUSING
COMMERCIAL AND INDUSTRIAL
FACILITIES WITHOUT SOME CORE
INFRASTRUCTURE INCLUDING WATER
AND SEWER AND WASTE WATER
INFRASTRUCTURE AND BROADBAND.
SO. AGAIN RURAL AREAS HAVE
FURTHER CONSTRAINTS EVEN GET
INTO THE REVITALIZATION AND
REDEVELOPMENT PROCESS THESE ARE
BASIC INFRASTRUCTURE CONDITIONS
THAT ARE IN DIRE CONDITION IN
MANY PARTS OF CALIFORNIA.
THERE WAS A NEW REPORT THAT JUST
CAME OUT FROM THE CENTER FOR
REGIONAL CHANGE CHANGE YOU ARE
WELL AWARE OF THE UP TO WATER
CONDITIONS IN THIS AND WE CAN
VALLEY. AND THAT'S A BARRIER TO
USING ANY KIND OF THESE TOOLS
BECAUSE THE BASELINE CONDITIONS
ARE SO ARE ARE SO IMPAIRED.
SO.
JUST AS A FEW.
OTHER INSIGHTS LAST IN THE LAST
DECADE WE DID A LOT OF WORK WITH
THE WITH THE CABINET AND THE US
STRATEGIC GROWTH COUNCIL LOOKING
AT.
KIND OF URBAN AND RURAL
DISPARITIES IN DIFFERENCES IN
INFRASTRUCTURE INVESTMENT AND.
WE DO NEED TO CONSIDER AS A
STATE THAT RURAL AREAS CONTINUE
TO GROW LAST YEAR CALIFORNIA
ADDED THREE HUNDRED THIRTY FIVE
THOUSAND RESIDENTS AND. THE SOME
OF THE RURAL COUNTIES ARE AMONG
THE FASTEST GROWING COUNTIES IN
THE STATE SO WE WE ALL HAVE AN
INTEREST IN MAKING SURE THAT WE
CAN ACCOMMODATE THIS GROWTH AND
SUSTAINABLE WAY.
THE HOUSING CHALLENGES WILL BE
FURTHER EXACERBATED WITH THE
IMPACT OF THE FIRES IN THE
FLOODS IN THE OTHER NATURAL
DISASTERS.
AND SO WE NEED TO BE REALLY
LOOKING AT THE IMPACT OF HOW WE
CAN ACCELERATE THE ABILITY OF
THESE TOOLS TO HELP US RECOVER.
AND BE RESILIENT IN TERMS OF OUR
INFRASTRUCTURE INVESTMENTS.
.
WE DO NEED TO THINK I THINK
ABOUT THE.
ADDRESSING EQUITY IN OUR
INFRASTRUCTURE FINANCING FROM
STATE LEVELS NOT JUST THROUGH
THE. TAX INCREMENT TOOLS BUT
OTHER KINDS OF BONDS AND AND
PROGRAMS THEY OFTEN
DISADVANTAGED RURAL AREAS IN
TERMS OF THE ALLOCATION CRITERIA
AND THE PROGRAM GUIDELINES WITH
THINGS LIKE.
MATCH REQUIREMENTS POPULATION
THRESHOLDS AND EXCLUSION OF
RURAL OR SMALLER COMMUNITIES.
THAT THAT'S A REALLY IMPORTANT
ISSUE FOR US I THINK WE COULD
ALSO LOOK AT.
STATE FUNDING PROGRAMS LIKE CAP
AND TRADE BOND MEASURES AND HOW
THEY COULD BE LEVERAGED.
SO THAT. THE INDIVIDUAL
COMMUNITY MAYBE DOESN'T HAVE TO
ADDRESS SOME INFRASTRUCTURE
NEEDS THAT SOME CORE NEEDS CAN
BE MET AND THEN THE COMMUNITIES
CAN WORK ON. KIND OF THE VALUE
AT AROUND REVITALIZATION
PROJECTS
I THINK PROVIDING CAPACITY
BUILDING TO ASSIST COMMUNITIES
AND ACCESSING IN LEVERAGE OF
BEING THE FUNDING IN PUTTING.
THE TI OF STRUCTURES IN PLACE
WOULD BE REALLY VALUABLE ALONG
WITH OTHER VEHICLES AND
PARTNERSHIPS AYE UNLIKE THE IDEA
OF THE. THE INVESTMENT VEHICLES
THESE KIND OF MECHANISMS CAN
HELP ALL COMMUNITIES.
AND I THINK YOU KNOW IN THE
PAST THERE UPSTATE PROGRAMS LIKE
THE DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT USE TO
HAVE CIRCUIT RIDERS WHO WOULD GO
OUT AND ASSIST RURAL COMMUNITIES
AND PUTTING PROJECTS AND
PROPOSALS TOGETHER. AND HELPING
THEM GET READY TO TO PUT THE
TOOLS IN PLACE
SO I THINK THOSE KIND OF.
MECHANISMS COULD BE LOOKED AT.
AND I THINK THAT ANOTHER THING
THE STATE COULD DO IS ADVOCATE
FOR CHANGES IN RURAL DEFINITION
WITH THEIR FEDERAL AGENCIES THAT
WOULD UNLOCK A FUNDING SOURCE
FOR US.
NOT JUST FOR PLANNING AND
IMPLEMENTATION FOR BUT THIS FOR
CAPACITY BUILDING PEACE.
I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO NOTE THAT
THE.
CALIFORNIA ECONOMIC SUMMIT
WHICH IS COMPRISED OF REGIONS
ACROSS THE STATE WORKING ON.
PROSPERITY AND OF HOUSING WATER
INFRASTRUCTURE. AS WELL AS
SKILLS DEVELOPMENT THEY HAVE A
NEW STRATEGY CALLED A WILL BE
CALIFORNIA AND THEY REALLY ARE
FOCUSED ON. WORLD PROSPERITY
THEY WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
RURAL CALIFORNIA'S NOT LEFT
BEHIND SO I THINK THAT WOULD BE
THAT A VERY GOOD PARTNER IN
ADVANCING SOME OF THE
LEGISLATIVE.
STRATEGIES AND PROPOSALS.
AND FINALLY I WOULD JUST SAY.
INVESTING IN BROADBAND
INFRASTRUCTURE IN A BROADWAY
INCLUDING IF WE COULD LEVERAGE
SOME CAP AND TRADE MONEY WOULD
HELP US MEET SOME OF OUR
INFRASTRUCTURE GOALS REDUCE.
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS AND
IT'S AN ENABLING TECHNOLOGY FOR
US TO USE OTHER KINDS OF.
INFRASTRUCTURE.
AND LASTLY THAT ARE RURAL AND
URBAN AREAS ARE INTO JAPAN
INTERDEPENDENT OUR LOCAL COUNCIL
OF GOVERNMENTS HAS DONE RESEARCH
THAT SHOWS THAT FOR EVERY JOB.
IN THE OFF ON FIRM AREA IT
GENERATES TWO JOBS OFFER SO WE
ALL NEED TO RISE TOGETHER AND WE
ALL HAVE A VESTED INTEREST IN
KEEPING RURAL CALIFORNIA STRONG.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
TRICIA DO HAVE A LITTLE.
THIS KILLING SUSAN.
SO THE QUESTION I HAVE IS HOW
WE MAKE SURE THAT. REAL
COMMUNITIES ARE AT THE TABLE.
AND HOW. THE O. SEEMS LIKE MANY
TIMES.
WE'RE NOT THERE. AND HOW DO WE.
CONTINUE TO PARTICIPATE IN THE
CONVERSATION.
THANK YOU COUNCILMEMBER AGUIAR
CURRY. I I BELIEVE THAT WORKING
THROUGH LEADERSHIP ORGANIZATIONS
LIKE C. SACK IN THE LEAGUE IN RC
RC IN THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT
COMMISSION AND THEN PARTNERS
LIKE VALLEY VISION THROUGH THE
NETWORK OF CALIFORNIA
STEWARDSHIP NETWORK. A WEEK
THERE ARE A LOT OF INTERESTED
PARTIES THAT WANT TO HELP AND
THAT CAN HELP GET THE RURAL
VOICE I THINK TO THE TABLE. AND
I THINK WE DO NEED TO BE MINDFUL
THOUGH. WE DON'T TRAVEL OUTLOOK
TO OUR ROOM AREAS SO. YOU KNOW.
WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT
VOICE IS HEARD AND I THINK WE
NEED TO CONTINUE TO ADVOCATE
WITH THE STATE AGENCIES AS WELL
IN THE STRATEGIC GROWTH COUNCIL.
FOR THAT ALIGNMENT AND.
I THINK THERE ARE A LOT THERE'S
A LOT OF OPPORTUNITY BY THE
VOICE NEEDS TO DEFINITELY BE
PRESENT.
SO.
THANK YOU THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS BUT. THANK
YOU FOR THAT PRESENTATION IT'S
CUT HIM MAYBE THINK ABOUT A FEW
THINGS.
.
YOU KNOW MY DISTRICT IS SOUTH
WAS RIVERSIDE AND.
NORTH INLAND SAN DIEGO SO IT'S
KIND OF A MORE.
RURAL AREA. BUT.
THE ONE OF THE BIG CITIES
THEY'RE ESCONDIDO.
.
IS AN OLDER CITY INCORPORATED IN
EIGHTEEN EIGHTY EIGHT AND THE
PIPES ON THE GROUND. ARE
DEFINITELY OLDER INFRASTRUCTURE
SO WHEN WE TALK ABOUT
REVITALIZATION AND.
YOU KNOW EVEN WHAT WE WERE
TRYING TO DO IT WE DEVELOPMENT
YOU CAN'T DO ANYTHING.
AROUND THEIR SPECIALLY AROUND
THE RAIL STATION. WITHOUT.
WE'RE DOING ALL THE
INFRASTRUCTURE OVER THE UNDER
THE GROUND THE WATER AND THE
SEWER.
TOM WE'VE GOT POWER LINES THAT
NEED TO BE UNDERGROUND LETS YOU
KNOW MULTI MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
WHEN YOU JUST LOOK AT THAT ALONG
AND THAT WAS ONE OF THE THINGS
WE'RE TRYING. TO GET US. IN
ORDER TO ENCOURAGE.
DEVELOPMENT THE AREA BECAUSE
EVERY TIME WE GET YOU KNOW
WILLING PEOPLE COMING IN TO LOOK
AT. REVITALIZATION EVERYONE WAS
STOPPED AND TURNED AWAY BECAUSE
OF THE COST OF THAT
INFRASTRUCTURE YOU KNOW.
UPGRADING.
BUT ONE OF THE OTHER THINGS WE
HAVE SOUTH OF THE GRAPEVINE
WHICH ONE OF MY FRUSTRATIONS
BEING IN SACRAMENTO IS.
PEOPLE SELL WELL IN ORANGE
COUNTY SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA OR LA
WELL WE'RE FURTHER. AND YOU
KNOW.
SAN DIEGO INLAND AND IMPERIAL
EVEN ARE KIND OF THE BACK
BURNER.
WE HAVE. A LACK OF RELIABLE
WATER SUPPLY SO IF WE WANNA
START TALKING ABOUT
REDEVELOPMENT AND HOUSING AND
ALL OF THESE THINGS OF THAT
REALLY NEEDS TO BE ADDRESSED.
BEFORE YOU WE GO TOO FAR SO IT'S
ALMOST LIKE THESE THINGS HAVE TO
BE TAKEN CARE OF BEFORE YOU CAN
EVEN GET TO THAT SO.
I THINK.
YOU KNOW THERE AT THE PROCESS
EASIER WHEN WE DID THE BONDS IN
THE LAST DECADE PEOPLE LOOKED AT
THE INFRASTRUCTURE CREATES A
COURSE OUR CROP ACROSS OUR CORE
INFRASTRUCTURE SO.
YOU'RE RIGHT EVERY TIME PEOPLE
DIG INTO THE GROUND AND THEY GET
LOOK AT THE CONDITION OF THINGS
IT'S A BARRIER AND IT ADDS A LOT
OF COSTS TO REDEVELOPMENT
PROJECTS SO. I THINK THE OTHER
PIECE OF THAT THAT WE COULD BE
LOOKING OUT HIS WATER NEW
TECHNOLOGIES THAT HAVE DEVELOPED
THAT WE CAN BUILD RESILIENCE
INTO BUILDING SUPPLIES AND AND
INFRASTRUCTURE EQUIPMENT DOUBLE.
STANDARDS IN BETTER SAID IN THE
FUTURE FOR RESILIENCE BECAUSE
THESE THESE DISASTERS ARE
POINTING OUT THAT THE NEED FOR
RESILIENCE AND ARE PLANNING.
AND I THINK FROM AN ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT STANDPOINT WE TRY TO
LOOK AT THAT AS DRIVERS OF
INNOVATION AROUND NEW
TECHNOLOGIES AND PROCESS SEASON.
BUILDING MATERIALS THAT CAN ALSO
BE MAY BE SOMETHING WITH THAT WE
CAN BUILD OUR OWN. OUTLET
MANUFACTURING AND OTHER
SERVICES.
I HAVE ONE MORE QUESTION JUST
BECAUSE PEOPLE WANT YOU WATCHING
THIS.
.
CHANGES IN THE RURAL DEFINITION.
CAN YOU JUST EXPLAIN BECAUSE I
THINK MANY PEOPLE DON'T REALIZE
THAT IS A BARRIER FOR MANY OF US
WHO.
THERE FEDERAL AGENCIES
ESPECIALLY YOU STA DEPARTMENT OF
AGRICULTURE HAVE A LOT OF
FUNDING FOR BROADBAND SEWER AND
WATER FACILITIES HOUSING
COMMUNITY FACILITIES BUT WE ARE
LOCKED OUT OF THAT FUNDING. IN
MOST OF OUR AREAS OF CALIFORNIA
BECAUSE WE. ARE TOO CLOSE TO
URBAN OR METROPOLITAN AYE
SERIOUS THOSE DEFINITIONS WERE
DEVELOPED REALLY FOR THE MIDWEST
WHERE. WERE OF RURAL AREAS OR.
HUNDREDS OF MILES FROM CITIES
THAT'S NOT THE CASE FOR US SO WE
HAVE WORKED WITH AGENCIES TO AT
LEAST TRY TO GET SOME
STANDARDIZED DEFINITE
DEFINITION.
OF IT AS SUCH AS RURAL IN
CHARACTER SO A COMMUNITY LIKE
WINTERS WOULD THEREFORE BE
ELIGIBLE BECAUSE THE PROBLEM IS
THEN WE DON'T HAVE A FUNDING
SOURCE WHICH OTHER COMMUNITIES
RELY ON TO MEET THOSE GAPS SO.
I'M VERY HAPPY TO SAY WE HAVE A
NEW STATE DIRECTOR FOR USDA ARE
RURAL DEVELOPMENT IN CALIFORNIA
WHO COMES FROM COLUSA COUNTY AND
SHE'S.
VERYINTERESTED IN HELPING US
WITH THIS ISSUE BUT I THINK IT'S
A VERY APPROPRIATE ISSUE FOR THE
STATE. DELEGATION TO BE ARE
PROMOTING FOR US.
BECAUSE OUT ENOUGH YEAH THAT'S
PERFECT THANK YOU I THINK WHAT
PEOPLE DON'T REALIZE THAT THAT.
IS A BIG BARRIER FOR RURAL AREAS
AND MAKE THEIR DEFINITIONS VARY
BY FUNDING PROGRAMS TO WRITE SO
THERE'S NOT A BEAUTY CONSISTENCY
WITHIN THE AGENCIES.
THE THINGS IS IT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MOVE ONTO KREG CAST A LIVE
CAST FOR THAT YEAH THANK YOU
VERY MUCH I APPRECIATE YOU
HELPING ME OUT THERE. STAFF
ATTORNEY FOR THE PUBLIC INTEREST
LAW PROJECT WELCOME THANK YOU
YES THE PUBLIC INTEREST LAW
PROJECT HAS.
REPRESENTED INDIVIDUALS AND
FAMILIES THAT HAVE BEEN AFFECTED
BY REDEVELOPMENT ACTIVITY.
IN SOME CASES BEING DISPLACED
BY REDEVELOPMENT ACTIVITY AND IN
OTHER CASES BEING ASSISTED BY
THE TAX INCREMENT FUNDS THAT
FLOW TO THE REDEVELOPMENT
AGENCIES.
AND SO.
I'M GOING TO PROVIDE A LITTLE
BIT OF PERSPECTIVE ON ON THAT TO
THE PAST USE LOW AND MODERATE
INCOME HOUSING FUND. AND.
AND HOW WE GOT TO WHERE WE ARE
NOW AND HOW THAT COULD HAVE
IMPLICATIONS GOING FORWARD.
AND THE FIRST THING THAT.
I PROVIDED AND HAND OUT WAS
FROM THE.
CALIFORNIA'S HOUSING EMERGENCY
THE HAND UP FROM THE CALIFORNIA
HOUSING PARTNERSHIP CORPORATION
JUST.
CAME OUT AND.
SEEMED APROPOS FOR REVIEW OF.
DOES THE LOSS OF REDEVELOPMENT
FUNDS BECAUSE ON PAGE THREE OF
THAT REPORT.
.
IS A CHART.
IN TIED TO THE ELIMINATION OF
REDEVELOPMENT AND THE LOSS OF
STATE BOND FUNDING FOR HOUSING
FORESHADOWED FOURTEEN PERCENT
RISE IN HOMELESSNESS AND AND
SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN.
AND THAT CHART.
REFLECTS THE FACT THAT THE
REDEVELOPMENT FUNDS FOR LOW AND
MODERATE INCOME HOUSING WERE
REDUCED THEY WERE ELIMINATED IT
WAS ZERO.
.
FROM A BILLION DOLLARS A YEAR TO
NONE. AND SO CUMULATIVELY.
WE'VE LOST SOME SIX BILLION
DOLLARS THAT WERE DIRECTED FOR
LOW AND MODERATE INCOME HOUSING
AND WE WILL CONTINUE TO LOSE
THAT BILLION DOLLARS A YEAR
EVERY YEAR.
BECAUSE IT TO DO. DISSOLUTION
ACT DOESN'T DIRECT ANY OF THE
FUNDS TO GO FOR LOW AND MODERATE
INCOME HOUSING.
AND.
SO THEN I'M I'M GONNA TALK A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT HOW THE
EXISTING TAX INCREMENT IS USED.
STARTING WITH THAT I HAD THIS
ONE PAGER.
WHICH.
WORKED WITH WOULD BETTER IN
COLOR A HUFF.
BUT IT IT DESCRIBES HOW.
W. AS AS WE ALL KNOW.
NO ONE PAGE OF TAX INCREMENT
ALLOCATION BEFORE DISSOLUTION
TWENTY PERCENT OF THE FUNDS WENT
TO LOW AND MODERATE INCOME
HOUSING.
AND EIGHTY PERCENT OF THE FUNDS
WERE AVAILABLE FOR GENERAL
REDEVELOPMENT ACTIVITIES.
WITH GIVING LARGE JUST LARGE
DISCRETION TO THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT THE LOCAL
REDEVELOPMENT AGENCY OUGHT TO
DECIDE. ARE BUT THE LOW AND
MODERATE INCOME HOUSING FUND
HAVE HAD TO BE KEPT SEPARATELY
FROM. THE GENERAL THE THE
REMAINDER OF THE TAX INCREMENT.
AND.
A NUMBER OF AGENCIES DIDN'T
EXPEND THOSE LOW AND MODERATE
INCOME HOUSING FUNDS THERE SOME
LAW IN EXISTING COMMITTEE
REDEVELOPMENT LAW ABOUT EXCESS
SURPLUS. ON THE CAN ONLY.
CREW SO MUCH OF THOSE FUNDS AND
THEY HAVE TO BE EXPANDED BECAUSE
COMMUNITIES WERE EXPENDING THEM.
WELL TO THE LEGISLATURE AND
TIMES A BUDGET SHORTFALL WENT
AND AND GRABS OF THIS FUNDS IN
THIS SUPPLEMENTAL EDUCATION
REVENUE AUGMENTATION FUN. AND.
FUNDS THAT ARE KNOWN AS C.
RAFFIN  RAFT.
AND THE.
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS DIDN'T TAKE
KINDLY TO THEIR FUNDS BEING
RAIDED AND THEY PASSED THE
SPONSOR PROPOSITION TWENTY TWO
IN TWO THOUSAND AND TEN. AND
WHICH PROHIBITED THAT ACTIVITY
BUT IN TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN IS
THE CREDIT BUDGET CRISIS
PERSISTED FOR CALIFORNIA. TWO
BILLS WERE PASSED AB TWENTY SIX
AND AB TWENTY SEVEN AB TWENTY
SIX ELIMINATED REDEVELOPMENT
AGENCIES IN AB TWENTY SEVEN
ALLOWED REDEVELOPMENT AGENCIES
TO CONTINUE. PROVIDED THAT THEY
MADE CERTAIN PAYMENTS
TO CONTINUE TO ADD TO HELP
BALANCE THE BUDGET.
SORT OF CIRCUMVENTING PROP
TWENTY TWO.
THIS AND THE CALIFORNIA SUPREME
COURT SAW IT THAT WAY AND STRUCK
DOWN AB TWENTY SEVEN.
AND SURPRISING TO ALL OBSERVERS
INCLUDING THE PRACTITIONERS NOT
ONLY. WE THOUGHT A FEW THE
REDEVELOPMENT AGENCIES WOULD GO
WAY WE LOSE SOME OF THE SLOWING
MUCH FUND WE LOST A HUNDRED
PERCENT OF IT. ALL FOUR HUNDRED
TWENTY SEVEN AGENCIES WERE
ELIMINATED UNDER SCHEME THAT WAS
NOT REALLY DESIGNED FOR STATE
WIDE APPLICATION.
AND IT DID SPAWN LITIGATION
THAT OVER TWO HUNDRED CASES WERE
BROUGHT. ONLY A HANDFUL OF THOSE
CASES HAD TO DO IT LOW AND
MODERATE INCOME HOUSING THOUGH
SO JUST A TINY FRACTION. HAD TO
DO WITH HOUSING AND.
.
ALL OF LOW AND MODERATE INCOME
HOUSING FUNDS THAT WERE
REMAINING WERE SWEPT.
SO NONE OF THE THE REMAINING LOW
AND MODERATE INCOME HOUSING
FUNDS WERE LEFT SO WE ARE IN A
SITUATION NOW IN THIS IS THE
KIND OF SECOND.
SLIDE THAT I HAVE OF WHERE
ENFORCEABLE OBLIGATIONS ARE
BEING PAID BY THE BY THE
SUCCESSOR AGENCIES EVERY YEAR
THE SUCCESSOR AGENCIES CREATE A
LIST OF IMPORTS OF OBLIGATIONS.
AND TYPICALLY THE EIGHTY PERCENT
CITE THE COMMERCIAL
REDEVELOPMENT WITH. WAS SECURED
TO BONDED INDEBTEDNESS
AND THOSE BONDS HAVE PRIORITY
ENTERED THE DISSOLUTION ACT IN
THOSE BONDS ARE GENERALLY
GETTING FUNDED.
BUT FOR MOST AGENCIES
THEY DIDN'T ENGAGE IN BONDING ON
THE HOUSING SIDE THAT MONEY A
CRUDE SAT.
AND.
GOT SWEPT AND NOW IT'S NO
LONGER AN ENFORCEABLE
OBLIGATION.
SO WE CAN SEE IN THIS TREE IN
THIS CHART WHERE MOST THAT
EIGHTY PERCENT MONIES COVER TO
ENFORCEABLE OBLIGATIONS AND THAT
BOOMERANG FUNDS THAT IS COMING
BACK. SOME GOING TO THE SCHOOLS
A BENEFITING STATE GENERAL FUND
MOST OF THAT IS THE TWENTY
PERCENT MONEY.
THAT WOULD HAVE BEEN GOING TO
AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
BEFORE THE DISSOLUTION LAW.
AND SO BECAUSE THE THE THE
ENFORCEABLE OBLIGATIONS ARE NOT.
HOUSING OBLIGATIONS
WE'RE NOT PRINT WE'RE WE'RE
WE'RE PROVIDING VERY VERY LITTLE
FUNDING AT ALL.
SO. WE.
SOME REDEVELOPMENT AGENCIES
TURNING TURNING OVER ARE IN THE
SITUATION WHERE THEY ACTUALLY
DON'T GET ENOUGH.
REDEVELOPMENT FUNDS THE
REDEVELOPMENT PROPERTY TAX TRUST
FUND AMOUNTS.
TO PAY FOR THE EXISTING
ENFORCEABLE OBLIGATIONS.
AND THAT'S THOSE SUCCESSORS ARE
UNDER WATER BUT THAT'S THE RARE
CASE.
MOST SUCCESSORS HAVE
SUBSTANTIAL AMOUNTS OF
REDEVELOPMENT PROPERTY TAX TRUCK
TRUST FUNDS TO ALLOCATE.
AND.
AND THOSE AMOUNTS ARE
INCREASING FROM THE EXISTING
PROJECT AREAS AND THE REASON FOR
THIS IS THAT THE THE
REDEVELOPMENT AGENCIES WERE
ELIMINATED BUT THE PROJECT AREAS
WERE NOT. THIS PROJECT AREAS
CONTINUE TO DO TO GENERATE
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS PER YEAR AS
NEEDED TO REPAY THE ENFORCEABLE
OBLIGATIONS.
BUT IT'S ALSO CREATING THESE
OTHER FUNDS NONE OF WHICH ARE
CURRENTLY BEING ALLOCATED FOR
HOUSING.
SO.
.
I THINK BECAUSE OF THE WAY THE
UNUSUAL WAY THAT WE ENDED UP
pTHERE HASN'T BEEN.
THE CAREFUL DEBATE AND DECISION
MAKING ABOUT WHETHER OR NOT THIS
SCHEME WHERE NONE OF THE MONEY
GOES FOR HOUSING IS THE SCHEME
THAT THE LEGISLATURE INTENDED.
SO.
THAT'S THAT'S THE ESSENTIAL
POINT THAT I WANTED TO.
.
BRING TO THE COMMITTEE.
THEY WERE HAVING QUESTIONS YEAH.
COMMITMENTS.
THANK YOU* ESCONDIDO HAD A
VERY ROBUST LOW INCOME HOUSING
PROGRAM. WE WON QUITE A FEW
AWARDS FOR IT.
AND WE ALSO USE OUR CD BG
MONIES.
TO HELP. OFFSET AND WE DEVELOP
USING THAT FOR SOME OF THE
SUPPORT OF INFRASTRUCTURE THAT
ONE AROUND.
.
BECAUSE WE WERE AN OLDER CITY WE
WERE ABLE TO REALLY.
ROOM MAKE AN IMPACT WITH INFILL
HOUSING.
AND IT WAS GREAT AND WE CAN ALSO
GO IN AND RE DO ALTER.
.
THE WHOLE NEIGHBORHOODS
BASICALLY AND CLEAN THE MOP AND
WHAT WE FOUND WAS AS WE WENT
INTO A NEIGHBORHOOD.
AND WE HAD LOW INCOME HOUSING.
DEVELOPERS YOU KNOW UP THERE TO
WHAT WONDERFUL PROGRAM.
THEY WOULD GO WHEN WE WILL CLEAN
UP AREAS AND THE SURROUNDING
AREAS WILL ALSO JOIN IN
BUSINESSES WITH SPROUT UP
NEIGHBORHOODS WITH STAR PAINTING
IT'S JUST NOT ONLY AREA WE DID.
IT REALLY EXPANDED BEYOND THAT
SO IT'S BEEN SUCH A LOS.
TO OUR CITIES TO NOT HAVE THAT
ABILITY TO KEEP.
KNOWN DOING ADS.
IT'S MY COMMENT.
BUT WHAT WOULD I WOULD SAY THAT
IS THAT IT DOES THOSE PROJECT
AREAS THAT WERE DEVELOPED.
GENERATING THE TAX INCREMENT AND
I DON'T KNOW ESCONDIDO
SPECIFICALLY BUT IN GENERAL DOES
PROJECT AREAS ARE ARE CONTINUING
TO DEVELOP THE TAX INCREMENT.
AND SO DOES FUNDS.
COULD BE ALLOCATED.
FOR CONTINUING BOTH.
THE CITIES AS A TAXING ENTITY
BUT ALSO THE LEGISLATURE COULD
MAKE A CHOICE ABOUT.
HOW HOW THOSE FUNDS ARE
ALLOCATED?
GREAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
APPRECIATE YOUR PRESENTATION AS
WELL. HIM GOOD AFTERNOON OF
DOROTHY JOHNSON YOU. WELCOMES.
NORTH REPRESENTS THE SEC
THINK YOU ADD MADAM CHAIR MISTER
CHAIR MEMBER AYE DOROTHY JOHNS
OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES
REPRESENTING IN THE FIFTY EIGHT
COUNTIES IN CALIFORNIA. AND WE
REALLY DO APPRECIATE BEING
INVITED TO BE PART OF.
THIS INFORMATION HEREIN GIVING
GIVEN THAT I COUNTIES ROLE IN
DRIVING ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT AND
OF COURSE THE PRESENCE STATE MY
NEED FOR HOUSING SOLUTIONS SO
WE'VE. WE'VE GOT IN DEEP ON A
LOT OF THESE DIFFERENT ISSUES
AND MY COMMENTS ARE GOING TO
TAKE IT BACK UP ABOUT THE THIRTY
THOUSAND FOOT LEVEL.
RHONDA AND REALLY I LOOKING AT
SOME OF THE PRINCIPLES BEHIND
THESE TOOLS AND THE USE OF
PROPERTY TAX INCREMENT FROM THE
COUNTY'S PERSPECTIVE SO.
WE OF COURSE BELIEVE THAT.
COMMITTED ON THE TOOLS CAN BE
USEFUL AND CLEAN UP
REVITALIZATION AND
INVESTMENT.
ALONG WITH THE INVESTMENT
PROGRAMS AND SERVICES THAT
COUNTIES
I DO PROVIDE TO THE SAME
COMMUNITIES.
KINDA GOING BACK TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENT FINANCE ONE A ONE A
LITTLE THAT.
SO PROPERTY TAX REVENUE WAS UP
TWENTY PERCENT OF THE COUNTIES
BUDGET I'M SECOND ONLY AFTER
STATES OF PENSIONS IT IS THE
LARGEST SOURCE OF DISCRETIONARY
FUNDING FOR COUNTY AND SO. IT'S
OBVIOUSLY CRITICAL FOR PUBLIC
SAFETY AND QUALITY LIFE SERVICES
THAT WE PROVIDE AND IT'S NOT
JUST OF COURSE TO RESIDENTS OF
COUNTIES BUT THOSE SERVICES ALSO
ARE PROVIDED TO RESIDENTS OF
CITIES AND SPECIAL DISTRICTS AS
WELL.
AND SO WHEN WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
FUNDING SOURCES FOR FORMER
REDEVELOPMENT PROJECTS AND I FTA
USER CREE AS ARE ALL THE OTHER
NEW TOOLS THAT HAVE BEEN
PROVIDED.
THE PROPERTY TAX INCREMENT
COULD BE CONSIDERED THE GOLD
STANDARD RATE BECAUSE I IT WILL
RELIABLY INCREASE OVER TIME AND
THE COROLLARY IF YOU INVEST IN
THAT PROPERTY IT WILL ALSO
INCREASE. A THE THE ASSESSED
VALUE.
SO BECAUSE PROPERTY TAX REVENUE
IS DISCRETIONARY IT'S RELIABLE.
BUT THE LOCAL FUNDING SOURCE
IT IS VERY IMPORTANT AND UNIQUE
FOR THOSE THOSE REASONS.
AMONGST OTHER COUNTY BOB
REVENUE STREAM SO. AT THE TWO
PRINCIPALS ARE CONCEPTS I WANT
TO SHARE MAY SEEM VERY BASIC MAY
SEEM OBVIOUS BUT THEY HAVE TO BE
SAD IF THERE'S ANY CONVERSATION
ABOUT THE USE.
OF TAX INCREMENT IN PURSUING
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT I COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT PLANS AND FIRST AND
FOREMOST THERE MUST ABSOLUTELY
BE CONSENT AMONGST ALL
PARTICIPATING AGENCIES ALL THE
SERVICE PROVIDERS. OTHERWISE YOU
ARE TRAINING CRITICAL REVENUE
FROM ONE AGENCY FORSAKING THEIR
INVESTMENT FOR ANOTHER.
I. AND THE CONCERN ABOUT
COMPELLED PARTICIPATION.
WHEN YOU'RE TELLING THE PUBLIC
TAX INCREMENT INTERLOCKING AND
ONE AGENCIES FUNDING LEVEL. FOR
DECADES POTENTIALLY WHEN THEY
HAVE ADDITIONAL PROGRAM DEMANDS
AND POPULATION CHANGES WELL INTO
THE FUTURE AND SO HOW CAN I
COUNTY MEET THOSE CHANGING NEEDS
OVER TIME.
GIVEN SUCH LIMITED REVENUE
AUTHORITY IN OTHER AREAS.
AS MY COLLEAGUE DAN CARRIED
FROM THE LEAGUE OF CITIES
MENTIONED A SEVENTY PERCENT A
COUNTIES ARE RECEIVING LESS
PROPERTY TAX TODAY THAN THEY
WERE PRE GREAT RECESSION.
THAT'S PRETTY STARLINGS OVER
THREE FOURTHS OF COUNTIES.
AND THE SECOND PRINCIPLE WE
WANT TO SPEAK TO IS
ACCOUNTABILITY AND THIS ISN'T
NECESSARILY REPORTING TO STATE
AGENCIES OR ADDITIONAL OVERSIGHT
BODIES.
BUT IT'S THE ACCOUNTABILITY OF
LOCAL OFFICIALS WHO ARE
INVESTING THOSE RESIDENTS
DOLLARS INTO PROJECTS AND MAKING
SURE. THAT IF A LOCAL AGENCY IS
COMMITTING TAX INCREMENT OR IN
SOME INSTANCES PERHAPS SALES TAX
TOT WHATEVER REVENUES ON THE
TABLE.
THEY OF THE MECHANISMS TO
REALIZE THE BENEFITS OF THOSE
INVESTMENTS.
UNTIL THERE WAS A QUESTION
ABOUT WHAT AREAS ARE USING.
THE NEWER TOOLS YEAH AFTER HE'S
CREE AS X. THAT ARE.
AND WHY HAVEN'T MORE BEEN USING
A AND YES I WILL WHOLEHEARTEDLY
AGREE THEY'RE VERY NO.
SEE SACK HAS BEEN WORKING WITH
OUR COUNTIES TO EDUCATE THEM ON
WHAT IS AND ISN'T ALLOWABLE
PERMISSIBLE. WORKING WITH
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT CONSULTANTS
HOLD WEBINARS AND SHARE WHAT IS
YOU KNOW POTENTIALLY ON THE
TABLE FOR COUNTIES.
BUT I WILL ALSO AND SAY IN
ADDITION TO IT BEING VERY NEW
THERE IS ALSO STILL SOME OF
THAT.
POSTER MATIC STRESS FROM RDA
DISSOLUTION.
AND THE IDEA OF TRUST OF WHAT
ARE WE GETTING OURSELVES INTO
HOW LONG EVERY TYING THE HANDS
OF THE CURRENT AND FUTURE NEEDS
OF OUR OF OUR COUNTY. ON IN ONE
OF THESE.
PROGRAMS.
AND IN TERMS OF OTHER COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT AND HOUSING
OPPORTUNITIES YOU KNOW COUNTIES
ARE COMPETING FOR FUNDING FROM
THE AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND
SUSTAINABLE COMMITTEES PROGRAM.
AND STATE FUNDING OPPORTUNITIES
TO PROVOKE DEVELOPMENT OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
AND OF COURSE SUPPORT
INFRASTRUCTURE IN THOSE AREAS
BUT UNFORTUNATELY WE KNOW STATE
FUNDING SOURCES ARE MASSIVELY
OVERSUBSCRIBED THIS IS AT THE
SAME TIME WHEN FEDERAL FUNDING.
IS DECREASING TO SUPPORT THESE
PROGRAMS.
AND SO AND RESPONSE ACCORDINGLY
WE'VE SEEN LOCAL SOLUTIONS FOR
SPECIAL FUNDING TO BE PURSUED BY
THE RATS.
OF BONDS OF WHETHER IT'S A.
PORTION OF LOCAL TO UT I'M
FINDING OTHER WAYS TO GROW THE
PIE SIMPLY THAN PEELING AWAY
FROM THE PROPERTY TAX BASE.
AND YOU KNOW WHILE THESE
INVESTMENTS ARE PROMISING.
THERE ARE STILL AGAIN THOSE
VERY HIGH VOTER THRESHOLDS THAT
MAKE THEM LESS ATTAINABLE.
AND SO.
THE THE UNFORTUNATE THING HERE
TOO IS THAT THE ALTERNATIVE A TO
ALTERNATIVE AGAIN RELYING ON
PARTY TAX INCREMENT.
.
IS THAT THAT MIGHT ACTUALLY
IMPEDE DEVELOPMENT.
.
THERE'S A STUDY FROM THE TURNER
CENTER FOR HOUSING INNOVATION.
FROM JUST EARLIER THIS YEAR
THAT SAID BY REDUCING REVENUES
AVAILABLE FROM POPPY TAXES IT
SIMPLY PUT INCREASING PRESSURE
ON DEVELOPMENT FEES.
AND A CURRENT FINANCING SYSTEM
THAT RELIES HEAVILY ON NEW
DEVELOPMENT TO FUND PUBLIC
INFRASTRUCTURE DRIVES UP THE
COST OF DEVELOPMENT AND AYE
EXACERBATES THE HOUSING
SHORTAGE.
SO YOU KNOW IN CLOSING I AM I
JUST WANT TO REITERATE THAT.
DIVERTING PROPERTY TAX REVENUES
AS MANY OF THESE PROGRAMS SEEK
TO DO AND LUCKILY WITH THE
CONSENT OF THE LOCAL AGENCIES.
IT MAY HELP HIGHLY LOCALIZED
PROGRAMS BUT WE NEED TOO AT ALL
COSTS ENSURE THAT WE'RE NOT
PUTTING ADDITIONAL STRAIN ON
OTHER PROGRAMS AND SERVICES.
ESPECIALLY FOR AGENCIES WERE
CHARGED WITH DOING SO MUCH MORE
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
CRIMINAL JUSTICE.
.
WHETHER THE COUNTY A SPECIAL
DISTRICT WHAT WHAT MAY BE WE
NEED TO ENSURE THERE IS CONSENT
AND PARTICIPATION AND
ACCOUNTABILITY AT ALL LEVELS SO
UP WITHOUT THANK YOU AND HAPPY
TO TAKE QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WILL BEEN.
GIVEN QUESTIONS.
WHY YOU OFFICE GOT FREED HIS
HEAD?
I'M LIKE YOU KNOW THE COMMENT
THAT I MAKE IS I UNDERSTAND WHAT
YOU'RE SAYING IS THAT THE THE
COUNTIES FEEL A LOT OF PRESSURE
AND HAVE SOMETHING ELSE TAKEN
AWAY FROM THEM.
AND TRYING TO GET PETITIONS
RURAL AREAS TO SIT AND ACTUALLY
COLLABORATE ON BIG PROJECTS.
SOMETIMES A REALLY DIFFER
BECAUSE THEY'RE SO LARGE IN
THERE SO CUMBERSOME SO MEGACE IN
SOME AREAS WHERE THEY WOULD WORK
A LOT BETTER YOU KNOW MAYBE SAN
FRANCISCO YOU'RE ALL ONE
COUNTIES CITY BUT.
IN SOME WAS TO HAVE THOSE
LARGER DISTRICTS I CAN SEE.
IT'S GOING TO BE A HARD SELL
MAYBE NEED TO CALL SOMETHING
ELSE I DON'T KNOW.
BUT THINK OF A NEW ACRONYM FOR
IN THE NEW ACRONYMS IT ASSISTS
IN. EXACTLY.
THAT'S ALL I HAVE BEEN LAND.
NO GREAT I WANT TO THANK THE
PANEL FOR.
FOR YOUR THOUGHTS AND AND
PLEASE.
FEEL FREE TO PROVIDE US WITH
RECOMMENDATIONS.
AND OTHER IDEAS AND SO YOU'RE
CONTINUES ARE ONE OPEN IT UP AT
THIS TIME TO PUBLIC COMMENT AT
THE PANEL IF YOU'D LIKE TO.
EXCUSE YOURSELF YOU'RE YOU'RE
WELCOME TO DO THAT.
BUT IF THEY'RE ANY MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC THAT WISH TO SPEAK ON
THIS TOPIC.
AND IF NOT.
UNLESS THERE ARE ANY FINAL
COMMENTS.
.
SOMEONE IS COMING UP SIR.
MADAM MISTER CHAIRMAN ANTHONY
TAMIL WITH THE CALIFORNIA
SPECIAL DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION.
ARE WE REPRESENT.
LOCAL AGENCIES THAT PROVIDE
QUORUM VITAL LOCAL SERVICES
FROM.
PUBLIC SAFETY IN WATER
HEALTHCARE.
TO MOSQUITO ABATEMENT AND
EVERYTHING IN BETWEEN.
AND THE LOCAL PROPERTY TAXES.
ONE OF IF NOT OUR ONLY.
PRIMARY FUNDING SOURCES OF.
WE THANK YOU FOR PUTTING THIS
HEARING TO GATHER AND
FACILITATING DISCUSSION SO WE
CAN BE PART OF. HOW TO BEST
CREATE THESE COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT TOOLS?
ARE WE LOOK FOR TO WORKING WITH
YOU AS WE HAVE IN THE PAST.
AND.
.
OUR LOCAL GOVERNMENT
COUNTERPARTS WITH
COUNTIES AND CITIES.
AND ANY OTHER STAKEHOLDERS.
ANOTHER WORKING ON THE SOLUTIONS
WE ONLY OFFER THAT.
WE'D LIKE TO AVOID JEOPARDIZING.
I AS.
SOME MY COUNTERPARTS APPOINTED
OUT.
THE VERY LOCAL SERVICES THAT WE
PROVIDE.
AND DIVERTING THOSE REVENUES
FROM OUR LOCAL SERVICE PROVIDERS
WITHOUT THEIR CONSENT.
A WE WOULD LIKE TO SEE SOME REAL
ACCOUNTABILITY.
MEANING.
EACH
TAXING ENTITY GETS A SUITE AT
THE BOARD.
A SEAT AT THE TABLE A FEW WELL.
THIS ALLOW FOR WHAT WE HEARD
EARLIER BUYING AND.
COMMON GROUND.
.
IS IF WE DON'T DO SO WELL
UNDERMINE.
THOSE VERY ESSENTIAL SERVICES
THAT WE'RE SAYING WE'RE TRYING
TO PROVIDE TO THE FOLKS.
HISTORICALLY CST AIDS BEEN THERE
WITH YOU GUYS TO TAKE PROACTIVE
APPROACHES WHETHER WAS THE YEAR
HE AYE FDA'S ARE THE CREE S..
REAL ESTATE TRANSACTION FEE OF
THE HOUSING BONDS SO CREATE YOUR
TIME NEAR INTEREST.
AND ARE MEMBERS OF FOUR TO
WORKING WITH YOU.
THANK YOU.
SEEN NO OTHER MEMBERS THE PUBLIC
PUBLIC COMMENT AS CLOSED AGAIN I
WANNA JUST THANK BOTH
COMMITTEES.
AND.
THE COMMITTEE CHAIR OF LOCAL
GOVERNMENT FOR HOLDING THIS
HEARING THIS IS THE END OF
TODAY'S HEARING BUT CERTAINLY.
NOT THE END OF THE CONVERSATION
AND PROBABLY THE BEGINNING OF
THE CONVERSATION THIS YEAR ARE
ON THIS TOPIC AND LOOKING
FORWARD TO UP TO ENGAGE IN WITH
THIS.
IN THE COMING MONTHS.
WE ARE NOW ADJOURNED